Hello my friends.
Hello people out there in cyber land.
Hello.
Human beings listening to one's and
zero's transmitted through computers.
Allegedly,
I don't even know how this works.
Uh,
this episode podcast is brought to you
by Ting Tang is a mobile service company
that is an independent company that uses
sprint.
What they do is they rent time on sprint
so you get the same service that you
would get with sprint,
but they have it set up their way and
their way is they want to do things is
evenly and ethically and just as they
want.
They want to make it as like above board
as possible.
A lot of the things you pay for when you
pay for cell phones are not necessary,
especially when you have contracts and
early termination fees and if you want
to get out of things,
it's very difficult.
That's one of the things that ting is
avoided.
They don't have any contracts cancel
anytime you want.
They don't have any early termination
fees.
They think it's silly and they also have
it set up in a very brilliant way where
you only pay for what you use.
So instead of having 120 minutes a month
or whatever it is,
a month,
whatever,
whatever your,
you know,
your pay thing is,
if you use less than that,
you don't know.
It's not like the company calls you up
and says,
Hey,
you know,
you should probably have a service for
less minutes because you don't use all
your minutes and then you know,
you have all these minutes that you
didn't use,
but you did pay for the waiting,
has it,
you pay for what you use and you would
be shocked at how easy it is to save
money.
Ninety eight percent of people would
save money using ting.
Um,
I don't know about the coverage but I
know because,
uh,
you know,
I feel like at this point in time,
Sprint like Joey Diaz love sprint.
He's had sprint for like 10 years.
Don't text him on it though.
We can't text him.
He won't accept phone messages.
You won't accept text messages if you
call him.
He wants to see matt full trunk called,
you know,
Mr.
Ms Dot Call Matt Full Toronto voicemail.
No voicemail.
But this is the,
this is not like some Hick cell phone
company.
This is the sprint backbone,
so it's one of the best cell phone
providers in the country.
So you get the exact same service,
but you own your phone,
they'll sell you an iphone,
five or 260 bucks,
they sell you all the best android
phones and you actually pay for the
phone instead of what's going on.
When you go to a lot of places like the
bigger name places and you'd get a
phone,
it's 500 bucks.
It's not really 500 bucks.
It's probably more,
but you have to pay over the course of
several years that you have your
contract.
You pay with the differences.
So if you're paying a dollar $199,
but the phone is actually $600 phone.
You owe them $401 that you'll have to
pay for over the course of your
contract.
That's one of the reasons why when you
try to leave your contract,
you have to pay money to get out of it
and this is all something you've signed
and you might not even realize it.
That's how it was for the longest time
contracts and early termination fees and
paying for x amount of minutes per month
and Tim has just stepped in and stopped
all that nonsense and I think it's going
to be the model that all cell phone
companies using in the future,
but right now things using it,
they have that new nexus five which is
fucking bad ass.
They have some bad ass google phones
now.
Three hundred 49 bucks.
You own it.
It never have to.
There's no payments.
There's no,
you know,
sits over conversations done.
And if you want to leave,
you're like,
fuck you,
I got what I want it right over the,
what is it?
P Metro pcs hop over them.
Hop over the 18 t who cares?
They don't,
they don't mind.
But uh,
use the code word Rogan.
Go to Rogan.ting.com.
The Url,
Rogan.ting.com.
And you can save 25 bucks off of any
things beautiful and delicious.
New Mobile devices.
That's Rogan.ting.com.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com.
That is o n n I t a human optimization
website.
If you look into getting shaped dirty
bitches,
if you're looking to get it in gear,
started,
look sexy for the summer pickups,
kettle bells and battle ropes,
and pick up one of those Keith Weber,
Kettle Bell Cardio Dvds.
Oh my goodness.
Extreme kettlebell cardio dvds one and
two.
They're fucking fantastic.
I love these videos because you just do
what he does and you're guaranteed to
want to have a heart attack.
Just keep up.
That's all you have to do.
And you see him doing it.
So you just try to do it with them.
It's fucking.
It's.
It's even better than going to a gym.
A lot of times when you go to a gym,
how often does the guy lift weights with
you?
You know,
not,
not very often,
but when you're following one of those
dvds,
you literally have to follow him.
He's doing it.
You got to do it too.
Don't be a bitch,
can't slack off.
Awesome workout and really good for the
body to.
It's a full body exercise type deal with
Kettlebells,
and if you haven't used kettlebells,
the number one urge that I have every
time I do this commercial is please go
to either a personal trainer or get a
really light kettlebell and go to
youtube and learn how to lift weights
and don't get crazy.
Don't hurt yourself.
Try start off slow and if you're
embarrassed by the fact that you're
lifting weights and it's only 18 pounds,
just don't tell anybody.
Keep working out,
but don't tell anybody on youtube.
Don't put it on Youtube.
Yeah,
put.
Put an outfit on like a furry,
like put like a crazy furry hat and plus
you'll be really shattered with
kettlebells in the beginning anyway,
so you'll probably hit yourself in the
head a few times.
If you have one of those big furry
masks,
it'll probably protect you a little bit.
Like if you have some Eric Cleans and
they hit you and your little chipmunk
face.
Yeah,
it's definitely a private,
private beginning.
Anyway.
Go to [inaudible] dot co and use the
Codeword Rogan and you could save 10
percent off any and all supplements.
Without further ado,
the full charges here,
Joe and Matt,
full truck.
He Music Brian,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joel Robuchon podcasts all day.
Was he drinking or any urine as fuck?
I just got off the road and I've
developed a habit.
Ah,
it's kind of my first day off.
So this is the time.
This is the first day off of how many
days on the road I was gone since June
11th.
We're going to call that three weeks and
I was in the Midwest the whole time.
I never came home and it's nice to see
beautiful Los Angeles,
California doesn't make you appreciate
the fuck out of me.
We got it.
So good out here.
People forget they're not 80 million
people out here because it sucks.
No,
it's because it's off the fucking hook.
It's really unrealistic though.
It's very unrealistic way to live.
We don't ever deal with weather.
I know.
That's what's so funny.
Oh,
that's all anybody was talking about
their open brains today.
Sure.
Do need some rain.
We never say that even though we're the
ones that need to remain.
Yeah.
We don't know.
Farms.
Yeah.
We're all farming.
Right.
When people out there say hope it needs
the rain,
you know they're talking to literally
talking about farm.
Yeah,
and their livelihood.
I saw a website out there called the
farmer's only.com,
which is like a dating site,
like an exclusive dating sod farmer
dudes him up on hog farmer Gal.
Commercial farmers will do a gay
farmer.com.
Can you have a.
are you allowed to say you're gay?
Can be a farmer and pick up other gay
farmers.
How many gay farmers are there?
That's a good question.
There's got to be at least 11 gay
farmers.
Only 11 though.
At least.
That's a worn out dating pool.
Yeah.
Imagine those poor 11 dudes just bang
into each other.
Jay Barnes and shit.
Tired from working all day.
I can't even put it in.
Go to [inaudible] dot com right now and
you know,
it's hilarious.
My fucking history comes up.
It switches to his first huge cock.com
and it's just guys.
That's all good.
Brian.
No hoes allowed.
I'm not doing that.
It will ruin your computer.
Is a weird,
very specific dating site though.
It's the most murder.com
specific I've ever heard.
I guess maybe they feel like a lot of
people wouldn't understand that
lifestyle,
you know,
hard work,
man.
Data,
non farmer.
Well here's what you can't do.
You can't be a farmer.
Find a guy or gal that's not a farmer
from the city.
Drag him out to the farm and expect it
to work out.
That's not going to work out at all.
It might work out.
It could,
but there's also that thing of a where
you're like,
yeah,
I'm a farmer,
and then the chicks like,
yeah,
that's cool because I like to.
I got some plants and stuff and you're
like not the same thing.
They don't know what kind of work hours
you're going to have to put in,
but they might,
you know,
some,
some people will have good work ethics
and they look forward to that sort of a
challenge.
It might work with the odd person put.
A lot of people have like regular jobs
where they get to sit down all day.
You imagine if you went from some sort
of an insurance sale.
I always go with insurance salesman
because it seems like one of the most
fucking boring bullshit jobs.
Phone and email all day,
and you're constantly like ass kissing
til I tell
them,
well,
you know,
this sort of the reason why this
coverage is important.
Well,
Joe,
normally I wouldn't say this,
but I think in your circumstance.
Oh,
shall we say in your first name over and
over again,
know you're going to love this cover.
Just the best thing you can get,
Joe.
Just rubbing you stroking,
get out of there.
They're exhausted.
You know that shit wears on you.
My uncle's car insurance guy and he,
he brings it home with them.
He's adopted the voice.
Oh,
like if I call him up,
he's like,
well,
Hello Matthew.
How are you doing today?
I love him.
He's great.
Oh ew.
Gross.
But he's from New Jersey and now he
lives in northern California.
Now he talks like a regular insurance
guy.
Wow,
that's hilarious.
What's up dude?
I love you.
I'm not making fun,
man.
Love people.
Always get mad if you talk about them on
a podcast,
but even if you say good,
if you say anything funny about some
funny shit that happened,
people get so upset.
Yeah.
Listen man,
we're all retarded.
Don't you listen to things we say about
us.
We're all retarded.
I've said worse things about myself than
anyone else.
The thing that the difference between
been an insurance salesman and being a
farmer though,
so I think the farmers are a little bit
more happy with what they think.
It feels like you get something done.
Like at the end of the day when you
brought in the crops,
when you fed the cow,
I don't even know which order you do
that in.
I have no idea.
You know,
whatever you did to bring in food.
Yeah.
No,
you can see it with your eyeballs over
the course of a couple months.
You can see the crops growing.
They say construction workers are really
happy because they actually get to see
what they bill.
They're also usually on drugs.
That helps.
That helps,
but yeah,
you're totally right.
I think building things,
getting things like set up a farm,
plant the seeds,
water,
um,
you know,
watch it.
You're,
you're essentially be facilitating this
whole construction process and if you
work in an office and just kind of
resets every day,
even as a comedian,
it's like,
all right,
I'm going to go do another show.
But there isn't that on you because you
just change your act.
You could have,
I mean essentially think about how long
it takes you to write an act.
If we were smart,
we would do is we would write to acts
two acts and we'd do one on Friday night
and one on Saturday night or one Friday
early show the other one Friday,
late show.
You're absolutely right.
That way you would never feel anything
stale.
It's just a matter of you putting it a
little bit more time.
I'm going to do that this week.
Do it bitch knew 45 Saturday when I
record my next special.
I'm trying to figure out how I'm going
to do that.
I'm going to do the next hour,
but I don't,
I don't have anything that I'm like,
that's like leftover stuff.
I don't think there's a couple of bits
with them.
I'm never gonna make it anyway.
Yeah.
You know,
so everything that's going to go on this
next one.
I'm going to just abandon ship after
it's over.
Then I'm going to be fucked.
Yeah.
You gotta start from scratch.
Matter of fired with no weapons.
People paid to see of noma.
Materials.
Dog Shit for a couple of months to do
some freebies.
But I start doing my.
I got plants.
I know a couple of different to take
place.
All of them.
Interdimensional
my move.
I'm actually think I'm going to.
The next one I'm going to do is before
the filming.
Do one of those in the August.
See The elves,
right?
What's up?
Sit down.
Sit Down with the dark and the light.
See if we can work this shit out.
I think you can tested territory.
So,
uh,
tonight the full charge.
I will be at the [inaudible] cafe.
It's a new.
A New Haha.
Apparently.
Yeah.
New Hollywood.
Good spot to fuck around.
Yes.
We got a lot of good spots to fuck
around too.
That's the other thing.
Imagine if you lived in Dayton,
Ohio and you had to do stand up.
It was like one club in town.
It's the only club for like 100 miles.
He just got back from there,
right man?
Yeah,
exactly.
And there's,
there's two clubs and there's like the
good one and the bad one.
And that's what all the comedians talk
about.
And there's a good one in the bad one.
Yeah.
And it's like you're always under the
supervision of the only clubs in town.
So say you want to go up and fuck around
some night,
get that new second act we're talking
about.
Oh,
you can't do that when they're paying
you,
you can't do that when they're,
when they're paying you.
And you also can't do that if you're an
open miker they're either.
Competition is so high,
they're gonna.
Be like,
oh,
you suck now.
Yeah,
sorry.
Yup.
That's the thing.
Open mic nights are fucking gigantic for
a comic.
Yeah.
And when you don't have open mic nights,
then you wind up doing like these,
these nights where like say you'll be
the host,
you'll be the host of a show and you'll
just do a couple of minutes and bring
people up and you know,
you're essentially just kind of getting
the audience used to the fact there's a
comedy show,
introducing the comedians properly and
hopefully getting a couple jokes in on
your own.
Yeah.
But there comes a point in time there
where you're,
if you're in a place where you don't get
stage time,
where you're not expanding.
Yeah.
We got lucky this,
this spot.
You could expand a lot.
Absolutely.
You can go to the ice house.
You can go to.
Yuck.
I've heard a lot of people shit on the,
uh,
the La scene,
but there's tons of places to do it
underground.
There's tons of art rooms and there's
tons of clubs.
Who Shits on the La Scene?
What Midwest people do.
New York people don't.
Absolutely.
Midwest San Francisco people do.
Everyone does midwest people shitting on
La.
That's hilarious.
That's a new one.
That's the lyric is only body.
You can't shit on the comedy scene.
There's too many of us.
I know and we got it.
We got all the New Yorker.
Well not all of them.
We got some New Yorkers.
We get some midwest.
All the ones who understand winter,
they move here.
If you understand winter and it doesn't,
you don't have to be in that like you
know,
you don't have to be.
It's good to be in that every now and
then to feel it because it's really
crazy.
But to live there every day,
six months when it's fucking freezing is
very taxing.
It's good to put the ankle weights on
every once in awhile.
Then take them off.
I go to Jen,
go January,
go up to fucking main.
Just hang out for a few days and then
you're done.
You get out of there and you're like,
okay,
I got it.
I have to do that.
Yep.
I get it.
Yeah,
and that's,
that's the good.
That's the upside of touring.
Why else would there be 80 million
people here?
Stop at Midwest.
Yeah.
Stop it to cry.
Whoever you are.
That's
talking shit on the La comedy scene.
That would be a Dana Stevens.
All I heard her say this,
my favorite.
I don't know who that is,
but almost all my favorite convenience
live here.
Yeah,
me too.
Like Bill Burr,
as soon as we got burned,
it was stan.
Stan hope doesn't live here,
but you take got burst and I guess
Louise in New York and there's always a
bunch of guys that are really good in
New York,
so always got a towel.
New York is always one of the best
scenes,
but patent is out here.
Um,
you know,
cowens out here.
There's cigarettes out here.
Joey Diaz is out here.
Ari Shaffir sometimes out here.
He's a,
he's a bow by coastal,
right?
Yeah.
He's a jet setter.
That arch fear internationally known.
Locally accepted.
Motherfuckers just got back from China.
Yeah,
I saw those pictures.
What was he doing out there?
Super Ball in.
He's just super bald.
Murdering it.
Selling out in China is murdering all
over the world.
Telling everyone to go there though,
like,
oh yeah,
no.
For him,
it sounds like it was a pretty bad ass
life experience,
but he.
He introduced us to a bunch of aspects
of China that I'm just so not interested
in experiencing.
Like what was the motor oil?
I'd be scared to eat.
How could you not eat or trust the water
or go to the bathroom?
Just going to the bathroom,
like leaving a nice bathroom just in
case if you have to go to the bathroom
somewhere else and it be like to the
point where you could die.
He's sit there too long.
People die in toilets.
They fall into the toilets,
like to get cell phones.
We had a,
a story that we're reading.
The other day,
guy dropped his cell phone,
went to reach for it,
pass out from the fumes,
fell in the wife,
went after him.
She fell out,
fell asleep too,
and they died.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They couldn't breathe.
Wasn't much methane and shit.
Water couldn't.
Yes,
it's awful.
They died for a fucking cell phone.
Usually taking a shit as a great
experience.
Not,
not holy.
It's just you gotta.
You can't shit in the same spot forever.
You've got to do something about that.
That's really a bad smell,
man.
Sooner or later you're going to have to
flush.
That was disturbing,
but it was even more disturbing is
already was telling us about gutter oil,
which is a,
um,
an oil cooking oil that they make from
raw sewage.
Oh my God.
I can't even imagine.
You have to watch it to,
to believe that you're,
what you're seeing.
Cooking oil is very expensive,
so a lot of people create their own
cooking oil and they use rancid meat
like old bones and meat and stuff like
that.
Boil it down.
And they also use raw sewage,
raw sewage mix in with it.
It's insanely fucked up.
We played a video of it the other day.
I just think we're not going to play it
again,
but I encourage you to go online and
anybody who wants to see it look up a
gutter oil anytime people are like,
you got to have some authentic Chinese
food.
Just be like,
no thanks.
Watch the red podcasts.
It was actually podcast Numero dos or
the first one,
dose doses.
We came back,
he wanted to talk to us about the
cooking oil.
We'd run out of time and it was one of
the most harrowing stories.
Almost puked,
didn't you?
I heard that.
Yeah,
and then I had to point out to them to
die hosted fear factor for six years and
I got really close to pukey.
People forget that.
I've seen a lot of shit.
I've seen people eat rats.
Right.
And that was almost throwing up.
It was just so shit.
I.
I started extra salivating right now
just thinking about it like that,
that feeling that you get right before
you,
you Yak.
She was.
She had these long like scoops and she
was scooping raw sewage out into
buckets.
Where do they carry the buckets to our
car and she'd put these buckets of the
card that you would drive off and that
you'd sell it.
And she was.
They were talking about how she bought
herself a house from the money from this
gutter oil,
so she'd been lifting manhole covers,
scooping out raw sewage when you're
doing it boiling and selling it and they
use.
They said one in 10 of those street
vendors are using
gutter oil.
I don't understand when it was.
Just don't use nothing.
Why don't you have to cook?
You don't understand Chinese food I
guess,
but yeah,
they cook and walks big bitch dude.
Raw sewage boiled down.
It doesn't even seem real
and he also poop in the streets.
It's normal for them just to poop in the
streets.
It's like they'll just drop trial and
just go take a load off right there.
You Go.
Down to skid row in downtown Los
Angeles.
We're still not doing that.
Some people are just happy with the fact
they have to shit differently.
I saw,
I thought the other day on a highland
know where that church is.
Highland and Franklin or whatever it is.
A guy was shooting this woman that kind
of,
I think lives at that church,
homeless woman,
but she just decided to not just go into
the lane,
that turning lane,
just take off her clothes and just start
shooting right there and cars were like,
are you really just shitting right here
is growth,
is that the light?
Just had to look.
Actually,
you didn't have to look.
Of course you did.
Why you have,
even if it's not pleasant,
fleas
shitting in the middle of the street.
Yeah.
Look,
quality of life is something that people
work really hard to preserve.
A lot of folks are really worried about
that,
especially as they get older.
Young people don't worry about it so
much,
but old people,
especially if you've traveled a few
different places,
you realize,
wow,
things can get out of hand if you have.
If you have too much homeless,
too much poverty,
too much this,
too much that you can get to a point.
There's examples over there today that
you could go to China.
You can see examples of this is what
happens when you get overpopulation and
people are devalued and life becomes
very different than what you're
accustomed to.
Yeah,
that's exactly what you're experiencing.
You know,
that is a good.
That's a good indication that maybe the
people in the midwest are right.
That maybe like being in a place like la
is just too fucked up.
I just think they're off with comedy
living there.
Like there's.
There's some real benefits to living.
Like in Seattle,
I was taught,
I was talking to Brian about that today.
We're talking about how great Seattle
is.
This is some real benefits to living
there as opposed to living here.
Absolutely lower number of people,
less stressed.
The energy's different.
It's not as chaotic.
It's not as showbiz based like there's a
ton of like positive things that you
could connect to a place like Seattle.
Good air,
good breathing.
Yeah.
The water.
The fact that it rains all the time.
You get depressed if you're a fucking
little baby,
but the reality is that's where life
come from.
Head.
It comes from water.
It's good that it's raining all the
time.
Sorry,
Kurt Cobain,
sorry Kurt.
I think Kurt was more depressed about
heroin is blaming it on the rain.
Yeah,
it was all heroin.
Just come on man.
It's a lot of people up there smiling.
You're shooting yourself.
There's a hell of a hangover going with
heroin attack.
Imagine that guy stayed alive.
If we could keep that guy happy enough
to keep making music.
What a fucking groundbreaking genius.
I know.
I really,
I really think it's a huge tragedy for a
lot of people.
Like to joke about it.
I think he was so fucking good.
I forget how good it is and every time I
hear it,
it's just like
so beautiful.
His Muse and an awesome impact.
I mean,
he had an awesome impact for the few
years that he was alive.
But yeah,
that guy changed the whole thing the
whole time.
It's just a fucking kid,
man.
I was at this guy's house,
um,
my friend's friend,
like a friend of a friend that we were,
uh,
he had a copy of it.
I think it was a cassette at the time
and he played nirvana.
We were both sitting around,
me and my friend going,
wow,
and the guy was like,
people didn't really play music for
their friends very often.
Like it would have to be something
really cool for someone to go through.
You've got to listen to this and I want
to listen to it with you.
Yeah,
I want to see your reaction.
Three of us are standing by this dude's
waterbed listening to this,
you know,
he had like a boombox and he's playing
it.
We were like,
whoa.
Do you remember which song?
It was always a team spirit or was it
teen spirit?
He's was the one my band played teen
spirit in high school.
Now every time my mom hears on the
radio,
she was like,
ah.
I'm like,
it's not my song.
He played a couple of other ones.
He played a cup.
Well otherwise from the,
uh,
the same album,
a couple of other songs,
we were like,
whoa.
That shit was a knockout because I was
into like punk rock and rock and roll.
That wasn't exactly metal at the time.
And we're kind of.
Jane's addiction was pretty great.
All these bands are pretty great.
Then Nirvana came along and just kicked
it.
Knocked it out of the fucking room.
They.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what a Nirvana did.
It killed hairbands.
Yeah.
Like any bravo.
He says that's because Eddie Bravo was
in a hairband.
Yeah.
He was looking at a metal band.
The hairbands and pissed.
Oh yeah.
They do not like Nirvana.
Well,
it came along and all of a sudden.
What?
You're allowed to wear flannel shirt.
I have leather pants,
tight leather pants like I'm supposed to
have.
We can't get them off.
I'm wearing platform shoes.
How come I can't wear platform shoes
anymore?
What?
Sneakers?
Whoa.
Converse.
All stars are you fucking kidding me?
I'm not wearing converse.
All stars in a fucking file shirt.
Uh,
what happened to be in a rockstar that's
over?
You got to be sad and regular now.
Yeah.
Is that what it is now?
You got to be sad.
Reg.
John Meyer doesn't seem very mayor.
No,
no,
no.
I'm in a mayor.
Doesn't seem very sad.
No,
I meant at the time.
At the time.
Yeah.
You had to be depressed as fuck to be
taken seriously,
you know,
lots of dudes on here,
alice and chains of heroin and he wrote
about it,
you know,
and you could hear what he was saying in
his songs to like that song,
bones,
dem bones,
and like there's songs called like junk
sick.
The whole album dirt is about heroin,
openly,
openly about heroin.
And it's awesome and it's fantastic.
It's their best album down in a whole
buck cherry.
I've never done cocaine,
but buck,
Buck Cherry has a song about cocaine.
Yeah.
That makes you want to try cocaine
because I'm not,
I'm not,
I don't want to try it.
I'm not in.
It just seems like a bad one,
but they're so good.
And it's about cocaine.
There's only been a couple of really
good songs.
There's,
of course the Eric Clapton Song.
Cocaine.
Yeah.
There's of course that one.
Is that,
was that,
um,
Derek and the dominos?
Or was that Eric Clapton?
Was that when he was with Derrick and
the dominoes?
I'm really not sure.
I think it's just eric.
He always just say it's by Eric Clapton.
That's a fucking bad ass jam.
That's one of the all time.
That's not a pro heroin song though.
No,
no,
no.
It was not a pro cocaine either.
I mean,
yeah,
pro camp.
That's what I meant.
No,
it's not a Buck Cherries.
That's a pro cocaine song.
Yeah,
it's.
I love the cocaine.
I love the lit up again.
Yeah.
I'm all lit up again.
It's a great fucking song and it's a pro
cocaine song.
Wow.
That cocaine song was actually not Eric
Clapton and it was a cover of a guy
named Jj cale.
Who did it well,
I'd like to hear the original version of
that now.
See if he could find that shit.
Yeah,
we'll get kicked off youtube,
but fuck it.
I think it's all fair use.
I think they can suck it.
I'm tired of this stupid.
Anytime we we.
I mean we're just playing shit that's
online.
We're not stealing any context and so
you typically commenting on things that
are readily available and youtube gets
mad sometimes people put up that fucking
crazy guy.
This is the original guy was an old
blues dude.
How old is this dude here?
It's 1976 to take around cocaine.
That guy looks like a subtle and elbow.
The whole thing that George Bush on the
drugs,
and this is the original version,
is that w on the drum that's.
See there's a conviction.
That guy's voice.
Yeah.
No,
he wrote it.
He meant it is done cocaine.
He could use a couple of bosses.
No.
Yeah.
He's not the most energetic guy,
but I like.
It isn't a weird though.
How some people's voices like in that
aspect,
when that scene or just more compelling.
Yes.
That guy's got a compelling voice.
Whatever reason I want to hear him keep
talking.
Exactly like Johnny cash.
Johnny cash.
Towards the end,
he was doing some of his best stuff and
he wasn't even singing anymore.
He was essentially talking.
Right.
You know,
but it's still so compelling.
It was heavy.
It fucking heavy.
Yeah.
Something comes through in people's
voices and I don't know what it is.
You know?
I don't know.
What makes one person's voice more
appealing?
One first person's voice more
emotionally connected to your brain.
I don't know what,
what,
what it is,
but like some people just have voices
that you like.
Orson Welles,
you ever listen to Orson Welles?
Yeah.
The guy who did the war of the worlds
did it on the radio.
Citizen Kane.
Yeah.
He was compelling to listen to him talk
or he used to do those wine commercials
towards the end.
We will sell no wine before it's time.
He just had.
There's something about his voice like
the guy could,
you could just have them talk about your
stuff and it would make your stuff more
awesome.
It was an authority.
We will,
so no more.
Once I started,
it was all fucked up.
Drinking wine and shit.
They have recordings if you don't like
yelling about how preposterous.
The,
uh,
the copy he was reading was,
he was awesome.
Citizen Kane came out when he was 25
years old.
Yeah.
He knocked it out of the park is first
try one of the greatest movies of all
time,
but then hurts what to do after that
hurts.
Squash that movie.
It was only out for a couple of weeks or
something.
The guy that was about willed,
William Randolph
hearst.
Hearst.
Yes.
First.
Yeah.
He squashed it because it was actually
about him and it was in a negative light
and then you know,
it was out of the theaters immediately
and it's not like you can watch the Shit
on cable back in the day.
Yeah.
He was just kind of.
It just kind of didn't work.
Even though we look back and we see it's
great.
It was off everyone's brain.
I think
so what,
what movies did he do after that
touch of evil,
but it was all.
It was all.
Nothing was as big as or yeah,
citizen Kane is the one that everyone
looks to as really great and nothing
else really.
I don't think.
Well,
he was responsible for that and of
course the war of the worlds thing,
that shit was huge.
People were jumping off bridges.
I don't know if that's really true.
I think snopes that,
yeah,
let's find out war of the world,
but it was something really incredible
what he did and it's something we do all
the time now.
We imitate a certain style,
like we imitate the news all the time in
entertainment shows we entertain,
we imitate documentaries all the time in
comedies.
He imitated a newsreel and everyone
thought it was real.
Well,
he read a book,
what he read it as as though he was
like,
it was a news report and so they'd.
But they'd also have like A.
Yeah,
it is a myth.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
Yup.
Mass panic and hysteria swept through
United States on the eve of Halloween,
1938 when an all too realistic radio
dramatization of the war.
A world sent untold thousands of people
into the streets headed for the hills.
This is a,
it's an urban legend.
Apparently.
That's too bad.
It's accurately misremembered like no
other radio program where essentially
they're saying is,
it's,
this is all from a bbc if anybody's
interested.
Gotcha.
Just the Halloween myth of the war of
the worlds panic and uh,
it looks like it's all very,
very exaggerated,
but they do it really cool.
Like they'd have,
they'd have like regular programming and
then they interrupt it with the news
reports of aliens invading and they'd be
like,
now back to our regular scheduled
program.
It just be like music and stuff.
This is funny.
Listen to what they said back then.
Radio is new,
but it has adult responsibilities.
It's the fucking Internet chided the New
York Times.
It has not mastered itself or the
material it uses.
So people were angry that Orson Welles
did this war of the worlds.
But imagine the New York Times said that
about radio back then radio,
his new holy Shit.
It's so funny.
That makes my skin tingle.
I can't believe I'm even.
I can read that.
I can read some people that were
writers,
The New York Times that we're
essentially talking about radio.
The way people talk about the Internet.
That sentence easily could be about the
internet.
Yeah.
That it has or has not mastered itself
or the material it uses.
Yes,
it's new.
But it has adult responsibilities.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That is the Internet.
Yep.
So what's going to happen is we're all
gonna get censored very soon.
Just like radio.
Well,
radio didn't eventually get censored
though.
It got sentenced for awhile and then
became satellite radio,
which is way more popular.
Oh yeah.
Satellite Radio is essentially smushed
regular radio.
It's when everyone knows they can get
opie and anthony every morning,
you know,
and you can get on your car if you're in
Pittsburgh or if in New York or you're
going to let.
You can get Howard stern every day.
You get to use his own.
There's two channels.
It's like,
wow,
why am I listening to this local guys,
this local guy that good.
You'll,
you'll give the local guy five minutes.
He says one wacky thing like this dumb
motherfucker.
And then you get to turn into Jim
Norton.
I know because you've got to sit through
20 minutes of commercials on regular
radio just to hear subpar content.
It's awful.
It's.
There's only a few good ones left.
There's like maybe a dozen in the whole
country is maybe a dozen radio stations
that are worth doing.
It's a mess.
Yeah,
and why?
What happened?
It's because it was censored.
They couldn't keep up.
You can't compete,
man.
If you listen to these not fucks that
tell you.
You can't say certain words,
you're going to lose us.
Yeah.
Where there's more of us.
Do you not get it?
They're really loud,
but there's way more people that don't
give a fuck.
There's way more people that would way
rather hear uncensored stuff.
That's why when you look at Internet
videos and they have a million fucking
heads,
that's what all that is.
It's like those are people.
Those are the same people that watch NBC
because the same people that listen to
am radio,
they're just fucking people.
They're adults.
They can pick and choose what they want.
They don't need you to tell them.
They should just oral abandoned,
ship,
abandoned ship.
All regulations here by now,
abandoned programming will now commence.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
If people like it to watch.
If they don't,
it's harder to get ABC than it is to get
cable.
Yes.
It's harder if you.
What are you going to do?
You're going to have antennas.
You're going to get fucking rabbit ears
and with the tvs even have those
anymore.
I don't know.
So you got to get cable for a lot of
folks.
Basic cable at least just to get your
local channels just to get the big four
right to get CBS,
NBC,
ABC,
Fox.
You just need an antenna.
Digital Antenna,
bitch.
All you need is the internet sober,
sober,
abandoned ship.
It's like you guys can't keep this up.
Comedy,
comedy clubs,
comedy clubs.
Still think morning radio is something
to do though is it helps.
It does,
right?
It does help if you have a good Dj,
if you have a good dj and they have good
people in.
I mean it's got to sell tickets.
People looking for things to do on
Friday night and they feel like they
know you a little bit.
You know,
they hear you in the morning like,
Hey,
I'm matt filter on guys.
It's pretty funny.
I like,
right.
That guy's name down.
He got along with Johnny Wild Johnny
wild and him had a blast together.
It was so cool listening to you guys.
Johnny wilds,
my favorite person.
Yeah man.
They got abandoned.
Ship,
abandon ship.
The fucking game of thrones has arrived.
It's over.
Yeah.
Abandoned ship.
And how great is it?
It's official over everyone on earth has
a podcast.
Abandoned,
abandoned.
I feel bad for him though.
You know,
a lot of people still go to school to
become a radio Dj,
you know,
like look at all the open anthony
interns that are in radio.
It's weird that it's still a profession.
Is it weird though?
What if you were a guy who was a really
good horse mechanic and you're really
good at like making wagons and you're
bummed out that someone invented a car
that's life.
Keep moving,
bitch.
She can be a lot worse.
And while you keep moving,
keep moving.
Keep moving,
bitch.
Yeah,
get up telcos.
It's how it's how it goes and we'll have
to go through the only way it goes.
Yeah,
it is.
The only way it goes if you try to do it
any other way,
you stifle progress,
so cut the shit and abandoned ship
that's can do it though anymore.
That's a big lesson in life.
You can insist that things need to be
the way they were.
It's key.
It can never be the way it was because
if it was,
you'd be a single cell organism.
You fuckhead.
Right,
okay.
It's ridiculous and those were good
times.
I guess there was a time of no
responsibility.
Yeah,
those were the days.
No phone bill.
Yeah,
just muck muck in the ocean,
chilling about waiting for the aliens to
come and mix the DNA in there.
Like in that movie,
you see that movie?
What movie?
Which one was it?
Promethium promethium.
The prequel.
Right to alien.
I saw like five seconds of that.
I was flipping channels that's got
chewed up.
Charlie's could have been fucking
amazing.
It's Charlie's Tehran in that the
hottest astronaut ever was pretty hot.
Pretty God damn hot and pretty bossy
too.
Something hot about a hot,
bossy,
bossy chicken space.
Right.
Running shit and fucking the military
guys on your terms.
I'll tell you it telling you what,
that would be great.
Special effects are pretty dope too,
but something was missing in that movie.
The movie just didn't quite.
I mean,
I enjoyed it,
but it just didn't.
It wasn't alien.
Was Aliens in it now?
Yes.
Spoiler alert,
but not as much came out.
Somebody got mad about us about the life
of Pi.
Some fucking dude was all angry online.
I mean he might be just be a troll so we
might be feeding trolls.
Right?
Like,
come on man,
you get a spoiler alert about the old
school.
See you next week.
Well you should've got on that shit.
If you really want to see it came out in
2012.
You still bitch.
When they don't understand is if you
really are that concerned about a movie.
If you hear any hint of somebody saying,
I'm talking about a movie,
you just stop listening immediately.
Like if we start talking about life of
Pi,
that's when you go,
all right,
they're going to say something.
Yeah.
Well we talked about it for like 10
minutes.
It's just been on DVD for a year.
How long does it take to shut off your
iphone?
Right?
Reached down.
Fast forward.
Yeah.
It's been on DVD for a long time.
We listened to the podcast.
You should be watching that fucking
movie.
You want to see.
You know what's funny?
When you have a movie like that and it
gets on NBC,
the network television premier that used
to mean something.
Right now it means you're slow as fuck.
You know?
It used to mean something.
They like get on Hbo first and then it
would be the network television premier
and you'd go,
Whoa,
nbcs got that movie.
You remember that.
It was like a big deal.
It's like,
well now this movie is legitimate.
This is the network television premier,
right?
Like,
oh no,
no,
it's not.
No,
this is you guys being super late,
right?
First of all is in the movies.
You always in the movies and we can do
go to the movies too.
I've ever.
Star wars came out and like 88 on like
NBC came out like 1988.
It was a big deal.
Remember?
That was.
That was a movie they kept coming back
to the theaters.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
I'm the wasn't.
There was TV movies when that was the
big thing where you would sit home and
there'd be like a movie that was made by
NBC or CBS and ABC and some of them even
lasted weeks.
Like they were just Salem's lot.
Yeah.
Made for TV movies.
We're big poison ivy with Michael J.
Fox and intimate came.
They did a new version of the shining
with the guy from wings.
I remember when that happened because
they were like,
the shining doesn't really keep it real
to the book.
Yeah.
And we're like,
yeah,
but it's
good.
Yeah.
They decided to UNCW,
rubric it.
Right.
And it wasn't,
uh,
wasn't so hot.
Have you ever heard the.
The idea is that there's all these like
conspiracies or like hints in the
shining of like the moon landing and
this,
that and the other.
There was definitely references to a kid
wore and Apollo tee shirt and there's,
there's a bunch of documentaries that
breakdown all the connections between
the technology,
the distance between the earth and the
moon being representative.
And all sorts of weird shit.
The documentary gave me blue balls
really bad though.
I was like,
alright,
I want to believe all this shit.
And like it just never connected that
well for me.
I think if I was a filmmaker I'd be
fascinated by it because I think Kubrick
was secure.
Brick is one of those rare minds that
was operating on a bunch of different
sort of levels at the same time.
Like I think that he was writing a
script and creating this sort of
theatrical piece where you'd see Jack
Nicholson get angry and,
but in his mind that wasn't enough and
he would add all of this like hidden
meaning things symbology and all this
weird stuff that he would add to it that
would just kind of leave people to
decipher like why exactly this number,
what exactly was that supposed to
represent?
And he had a bunch of shit attached to
it that didn't necessarily even have to
be in the movie.
That's it.
Room to 37.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I wasn't crazy about it.
I couldn't get through it.
Um,
but I thought it was interesting that
people thought he was,
he was the actual one who faked the moon
landing.
He was the one hired to do that.
Well,
the theory being,
well there's zero evidence that shows
that he did,
but there is a bunch of evidence that
shows that he was working with Nasa and
that he got a lot of consulting with
them when he was creating a 19,
69 when he was doing in 2001.
That makes sense though.
Of course,
of course it makes sense that he would
consult with them.
Why would you,
if you were a huge movie movie producer,
you're,
you know,
a guy who makes these perfect movies.
I mean he made Dr.
strangelove was fantastic and he'd made.
He was a wizard.
Clockwork orange.
The guys wizard.
Yeah.
A guy like that must put incredible
amounts of consideration to every single
aspect when you're doing something like
space travel.
Yeah.
Of course you would have some sort of
relationship with NASA.
Right?
But if someone was going to be able to
fake the moon landing,
probably be that dude.
Yeah.
I mean,
it probably be only that dude at that
time,
George Lucas,
he was a baby at that time.
George was probably like in his twenties
going on.
That was 1969 to 1972 was when they
filmed it in 68.
And I'm just kidding.
Do you ever see that Roger Moore
documentary or Roger Moore?
James Bond when he's,
uh,
he's being chased by these bad guys that
he runs through a set of the moon.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
I never got that as a kid,
but yeah,
I get that.
Yeah.
It's funny.
They were filming the Moon,
filming the Moon Landings,
how to rock it out and Roger Moore goes
running through it.
Yeah.
James Bond.
Sean connery and Roger Moore had to be
Roger Moore because they turned into
comedy is after Roger Moore.
Yeah.
It's an interesting term.
Wacky.
Yeah.
Double.
Oh,
seven became like a little wacky sort of
a burt reynolds ask.
It's kind of weird.
It was like a smokey and the bandit
type,
almost like Benny Hill music playing
while he's chasing people around.
Right.
And he was always.
Yeah.
And then you get Daniel Craig,
which is totally the more like the book,
right?
He's more like the real double o seven
literature,
literary character.
Have you seen the double of seven
documentary where it takes you from the
beginning all the way to the current?
No,
because it's really good because,
um,
it started obviously with that guy
writing books about James Bond and there
was even an American version called
Jimmy bond first.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It was all black and white and he's got
an American accent and oh my God,
it's really bad.
His name is Jimmy Bond.
Yeah.
They made American version for the
British army.
Sean connery.
Please find that.
And you know about the,
you know about the guy that only did one
James Bond movie?
No,
there's a guy that that was between
Roger Moore and Sean Connery and he kind
of got influenced by the hippie movement
and grew his hair all long and started
doing all these public statements about
the war.
And they dropped him in a second because
he didn't fit the image anymore.
No Shit.
And he was really disappointed.
He's always been disappointed by it.
You know that he did that,
that he did that because you only got
one movie.
He would have been set for life and he
kind of locked them out too.
Right?
They locked him out and he.
He seems to think he was kind of
influenced by like all these outside
guys like,
Hey,
you have this voice now.
You need to express all these opinions,
and he felt like he didn't necessarily
really want to do it.
He just felt pressured to do it.
The first guy was Barry Nelson in 1954.
That's the American you think?
Or is that somebody
for Sean Connery?
I Dunno.
I'll read this.
In early 1954,
Ian Fleming was paid a thousand dollars
for the television rights to Casino
Royale.
Oh,
is a TV show.
It was adapted into an hour long TV
special and was broadcast on CBS October
21st 1954 as an episode of climax
mystery theater.
They didn't even know.
They didn't have climax back then.
Peter Lorre.
What is that?
This is what you're talking about.
Oh,
this is it.
The TV show is the first episode,
I guess Linda Christian.
Boy,
that was good stuff back then.
Climax.
Look at it's all wiggly and shit.
When they have the logo up,
it can't sit still.
I feel like it moves.
Look at this guy.
It doesn't look dangerous.
Not even in focus.
That's killed plenty of men and women.
It's made beggars with many and
billionaires have a few mighty fueled in
French gambling casinos.
This is called a shoe holds.
The cards were baccarat.
Kings of gambling games,
and its purpose is to make sure that no
one can pull any funny business like
dealing from the bottom game to be
played tonight is for the highest stakes
of all.
A man is going to wager his life.
Climax Presents Casino Royale on the
best seller by Ian Fleming.
Stars Barry Nelson.
Pull him out while he's doing this.
Linda Christian,
throwing them on the ground and it's so
funny that all intro to a show.
He's cool,
man.
Look,
he's just throwing the cards away.
What if there's like an old guy
introducing like house?
Look at this.
Act One,
Casino Royale Act One.
Oh my God,
this is so fake looking.
It's so weird.
Gun Shot.
He missed him and then he hit the tree.
Well they're really shooting that tree
with the flux out about.
Okay.
Stand on there.
Whether it's shooting at the tree by
winning he run,
but I wouldn't to the ground.
You're lucky to Miss James Bond.
Yup.
That's.
See original James Bond.
Never catch him now.
I'll never catch them now you bet guys.
Got a 10 step headstart.
That's it.
I'll never catch up now.
Come on.
People are so unathletic then you
imagine if you heard that kind of shit
from um,
what's his name?
Daniel Craig.
No,
the other guy.
Sean connery.
American guy.
James Bond.
James Bourne.
Identity Board.
It's a board.
Imagine Jason Bourne said something like
that.
Oh,
he's too far away now and move it in
right there.
So what kind of pussy am I paying money
to say it's just another movie where he
just goes to eat lunch.
There was another guy in 1956.
His name was Bob wholeness and Baba
wholeness provided the voice for James
Bond in the South African radio
adaption.
So he was one of the James Bonds but not
a physical James Bond.
Then there was Bob Simmons and Bob
Simmons is apparently the guy
that,
uh,
that
stop doing it.
Right.
Um,
or was it David Nivon?
I'm not sure.
This was in the sixties whenever.
Uh,
there was this one guy did one movie,
George Lazenbys at him.
I'm not sure.
Hmm.
I don't know which guy it is.
It's either George Lazenby or David
Niven.
I would imagine it would be lazy and be
for some reason.
What are the most interesting things
about the documentary is a in the
eighties,
but all the,
all the James Bond movies are done by
one family.
Really?
Yeah.
Except for one.
And Sean Connery was friends with this
outside director and they did a James
Bond movie in the eighties and it came
out the same time as a Roger Moore James
Bond movie.
This I didn't know came out like the
same week to James Bond movies.
Two different.
James Bond's wow.
Yeah.
It was lazy and be lazy and B was the
only guy that only played it once,
but it doesn't say anything in his
wikipedia about that just says,
I guess it's just not that important to
some people that they put it in
wikipedia.
Interesting,
man.
Yeah,
it's fascinating too,
man.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Here it is.
Yeah.
I guess,
uh,
yeah,
there was some,
some issues.
I'm fascinated with different actors
playing the same character,
especially when it's supposed to be
seamless.
How about the Hulk in modern times?
How many hawks or they've been.
There's been,
there's been three in modern times.
Has Been Eric Bana.
And then there was a homeboy from
American history x.
what's his name?
Uh,
Norton.
Ed Norton.
Yeah.
And then there's the new guy.
Mark ruffled lows.
Oh,
is he?
he's the best dog ever.
Well,
how dare you tell her.
He's fantastic.
Oh,
you wouldn't like him when he's angry,
dude.
The secret is he's always angry.
That's the secret.
He says that,
and he turns into the hulk smashing
shit.
He's the best hole cover.
The hulk is the best luck ever now.
And he's the best hook ever.
He's the best banner.
Okay.
Did you know that the original banners
name was Bruce?
And then for TV they changed David
Bruce's gaze.
Fuck yeah.
And that hilarious in the days when that
was out.
Yeah.
I guess that was the seventies.
Like when was the hawk?
Was it the seventies and the eighties?
Late Seventies.
I remember watching it.
Yeah.
So in those days Bruce was associated
with gay men.
Like it was a joke.
Oh look,
here comes bruce.
No Kid.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you were,
if you were gonna,
call someone gay,
he'd say is his name Bruce.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Bruce Lee.
Right?
It's one of those manly guys ever.
One of the baddest motherfuckers of all
time was a bruce springsteen.
What about that?
Come on,
bitch.
That's manly shit.
Right?
You can have.
Can have gender.
We didn't know there's all yours.
You get your Adam's apple trimmed out.
You're out of the book.
That is like actually happening.
Right?
He's a,
he's getting very feminine.
Allegedly.
He's getting very feminine.
He's getting it.
He didn't like his Adam's apple.
So he had some shit done to it,
but who knows.
It could have been the reality might've
been,
might had something wrong with his
voice,
might have something wrong with his
neck.
Could they be assholes just insinuating
that he was becoming a woman.
I didn't.
I didn't say.
However we got Lee and Bruce
springsteen.
That's all I'm saying.
I mean gender was a bad motherfucker for
like one weekend in the sixties.
He was Olympics wherever it was.
He might've just had a gross neck bone
or to like some of those people have
those little neck things going on.
It's disgusting.
It's true.
That's like that's an issue with a lot
of older folks.
Their next get really creepy.
He's not a young guy.
They do.
They get creepy.
Like you look at their face and you
don't mind looking at their face at all.
Like you know you have a pleasant face.
Sure.
They see their neck balls.
This is going to end terribly.
Then you realize,
oh for all of us,
everyone's going to get that Turkey neck
one day.
If you're lucky,
if you're lucky to stay alive long
enough for your skin to have a bad
relationship with your face,
just slowly but surely.
Speaking of that,
I did this cryo chamber thing today and
we were talking about it before the
podcast that I polished tweets up.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo told me about this and I've
read about it online and I had a Ian
Mccall who's a fighter in the UFC,
one of the top flyweight contenders.
He does it every day.
So I was like,
okay,
I've heard too much about this.
I got to give this a try.
So I went to this place called the Cryo
health center in.
I'm in La today and go into this.
It's like sort of like a suntanning
booth I guess I got.
Or a sauna?
Yeah,
like a song,
like a big metal sauna and it's 240
degrees below zero in there.
And you go in there for two minutes
naked at 240 degrees below zero.
I got a hard on.
Um,
I very hard.
Really?
No,
it's hard to breathe.
It's one of the strange feelings ever.
How long,
how long?
Only two minutes.
I looked at.
That's me and they're two minutes minus
two forties,
240 degrees below zero.
It's weird how cold that feels and if as
long as you only do it for a couple
minutes,
it's actually really good for your body.
You feel your eyes getting frozen or
anything?
No.
That's a weird thing about eyes,
man.
We've talked about this before.
We talked about why don't your eyes get
cold when it gets really cold out.
It's really weird.
Like the wind can whip into your eyes
and it hurts,
you know,
and that can be cold because that's
like.
It's like the physical act of something
like that.
The actual Ehr itself smacking into
your.
Your eyeballs.
That can hurt but regular cold.
Unless it gets really,
really fucking cold.
Your eyes don't get cold.
Oh my eyes weren't called.
The most noticeable thing wasn't just
that.
My skin was really cold,
but it was hard to breathe.
It's so cold.
Everything constricts you standing there
naked.
How safe is this?
Safe is fuck.
Really.
Don't be a pussy.
Get in there.
Seems safe.
It looks like a super easy to open up
the door lock champs.
Is there a lock on the door?
Well,
only if someone really doesn't like you
definitely die.
That's one thing.
Someone locked you in there.
You're if you're naked.
Yeah.
I don't know how long you're going to
laugh,
but what if that locked just stopped
working.
He never locked.
They can't have a swinging door.
Just opened the door.
It's not hard.
It's thick as fuck though.
Be Hard to claw your way out of that in
time.
Don't.
Don't get in this booth if you're in.
If you're in a fraternity or something
for eternity,
like eight other frat bro Brothers would
fucking hold the door.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We used them.
Or at least you'd have horrible
frostbite where they have to remove like
half the skin of your back.
You know,
like.
Sorry Bro.
He listened to your five Beta Kappa for
life.
There's no more haze and you gotta pass
where the senior Tattoo already.
Okay.
We've decided.
We all voted on it.
We all voted in assholes.
I was never joined one pass by Frat the
other day.
It was all these dudes were in front of
the house and they were playing
football,
playing catch,
like on the lawn and there was like a
bunch of them in there drinking beers
like this is so like stereotypical,
like did you guys like see a movie and
you decided to go to school,
do everything that they did in the
movies.
Wacky Frat guys?
No.
You said it's pretty funny.
It's all about that.
Also,
you know,
like people hanging out in the front
porch and drinking and having parties.
But living next to that with your
family,
did you see the reactions that a seth
rogen got by some wacky feminist?
Um,
when it came to,
uh,
that guy that was shooting people up at
Santa Barbara know what happened?
She was this woman,
well,
you know,
the guy was shot at the epicenter,
Barbara.
Well,
this woman somehow or another implied
that it's cartoonish depictions of
women,
like in Seth Rogan's movies that lead
men to have these horrific ideas of what
women really are.
And then like somehow or another lead to
them killing them.
Especially in that one story.
It's a terrible,
it's terrible connection because he
killed men to killed more men,
in fact,
and he killed women.
He killed four men and women.
Right?
I mean,
he was just a sick fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
the kid was a mess.
But the idea that somehow or another
seth Rogan's movies like have to be
gender balanced,
you know,
and at the sacrifice of what,
of comedy.
Like they can't be caricaturists,
they can't,
whoever's in the film that it can't be a
woman with long nails is really done as
big tests.
If that happens,
a guy's going to murder people.
Right.
And what about actual cartoons?
Like,
don't you know what I mean?
There's all those crazy depictions in
that.
If you heard about his new movie,
it's about North Korea.
Yeah.
And are they are already saying like,
like this is a threat of war and if this
movie comes out that,
that they're threatening war on us
because of this movie,
they can't go to war with us.
That's ridiculous.
For one movie,
for the new Seth rogen movie about
assassinating Kim Jong.
Oh,
it's called a some.
Could you imagine?
Could you imagine if North Korea goes to
war and as for a fucking James Franco
movie,
we'll be like,
we don't like them either.
Not going to kill him.
Just troll them on instagram.
You don't have to.
You don't have to do this.
You have to go to.
Should have went to war over the south.
But that South Park movie team America.
Yeah,
that was way worse.
That was when they drew the line in the
sand though.
That was great.
That was the first blow.
Then like one more time.
Mother fuckers.
One more time.
They're always threatening war though,
aren't they?
I don't know.
I think they really get the mic.
Rib doesn't come back this week.
We're going to war with you.
While they're very hurting.
They don't have much money.
They say when you fly over North Korea
at night,
it's all dark because they can't afford
to keep the lights on.
Wow.
It's not a good place.
I don't want to go.
We had Shane Smith from vice and he
talked about his vet,
his visits to North Korea.
He said it was the craziest thing ever.
Like they pretended that they took him
to a restaurant,
it was all set up,
but there was no one else there with him
and he said it was so obvious that by
the way,
that people move,
they didn't move with like,
like people who are comfortable working
there.
It was like,
it was all totally new experience for
them.
So they probably were people that were
like forced into this position to
pretend that it was a restaurant for
American journalists.
Right.
And he's going,
whoa.
And then he got Dennis Rodman going over
there playing basketball and grab ass
with a fucking kid than the kid winds up
being the new dictator now.
Right.
I miss the.
I Miss Dennis Rodman being on TV every
day.
He could be on tv every day if someone
was smart.
Yeah.
Just follow them with the camera.
How's that gone on?
Every reality show he should.
A good reality show producer.
You're telling me you can produce a TV
show about a slippery road,
but you can't produce a TV show about a
giant black man with facial piercings
that likes to get drunk or crazy.
Wait a minute.
He's a celebrity.
He plays basketball with murderers.
Yeah.
He plays basketball with the guy who
killed his own family.
Okay.
The guy killed his own family because he
was worried that they were going to
assassinate him.
He goes over there and plays basketball.
With that.
You can make a show in Kaiser,
so.
So you can make a show about dudes who
hunt alligators or swamp people.
There's something.
It's like dudes giving away parking
tickets as a show.
Exactly.
They have a guy makes pools.
A guy makes pools.
He's the pool master on the next episode
of Crochet.
Yeah.
What the fuck that he crochets a sheet
they not have.
How does ask Robin?
None of the show.
Why don't I produce it?
What am I doing?
You should.
I should be the Ryan seacrest of the
Dennis Rodman shows.
That's how he got started with this
whole Kim Kardashians thing.
Come in and introduce it like an old
James Bond TV show.
Is Ryan seacrest embed with Satan or did
you just know?
What do you think?
Spawn.
I think he's in bed with them.
Let me think about what is a part of.
It's not star search.
American idol.
Yeah.
That's part of American idol.
It's part of a keeping up with the
Kardashians and during that time he has
time to be the host of top 40 radio
every morning.
Yeah.
What does he do on the.
I never watched that show producer
of it.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
You created it.
He's on the radio every morning.
He gets it.
How's the on the radio every morning?
I don't do that at the time.
A lot of people.
That means a lot of people like him.
Oh yeah.
He's very likable or maybe this.
A lot of people don't hate him.
I think that's more like it.
Right?
There's a lot of that.
Go.
Don't know who the fuck he goes.
Do you know who the fuck is?
Barely.
I barely know you and I know you're
pretty good,
right?
Not have fucking dude.
Do you know that dude?
No.
I don't know anything,
any of his opinions or anything like I
know certain dudes.
Right.
I feel like if you got had a couple of
drinks with val kilmer,
you pretty much know what's up.
Right,
right.
He'd be testing the bounds of reality.
Yeah.
He'd probably throw some mushrooms down
the hatch and go walk through the
parking lot.
You'd be like,
vow,
come on man.
We gotta get Outta here.
Babysitting val kilmer like one every
night.
Someone's got to babysit him.
That's how it is.
Hang out with val.
You gotta.
Make sure he makes it home.
You never know what he's going to pop.
Pop and trip.
Yeah.
That's a dude that like used to be like
one of the biggest sex symbols in the
country.
Absolutely.
And then he just decided to just keep
eating.
Yeah,
just totally tapped out.
Just done.
I'm done.
He used to be the iceman.
I'm going to get big.
Yeah.
He's like,
fuck it.
I got.
I'm fine with this.
He,
yeah,
he was a.
wasn't he like a superhero?
What's that?
Saint.
The saint.
Yeah.
He was a superhero.
He was the saint.
Yeah.
And he always put shit fucking
superheroes that.
But all the superheroes,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't know that one that well.
Did he not see the watchmen?
Did you not read Spiderman?
How come you get to be the same?
Yeah.
I don't know quite why gets to be Peter
Parker and you've got to be the fucking
saint.
No,
that's some bullshit bad deal with that
is bull shit.
He did.
He did play Jim Morrison and the doors.
Right?
That's where he cooked his brain and he
cooked it.
He's like,
he got in touch with his fat side in
that movie.
Like he used to be a thin dude,
but then he played the 27 year old Jim
Morrison and got his gut all all amped
out.
You ever doubt ever in your life that
Val kilmer was a bad motherfucker?
You got to watch that movie.
Tombstone.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh my goodness.
He puts on a command performance in
tombstone.
You ever seen top secret?
Yes.
That's funny.
Shit.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
I tried it and seen as the dad.
I need that.
You think it's funny because when I was
a kid,
I was such a fan of naked gun and I
tried to watch all those movies like
Kentucky Fried Movie Top secret.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
They all just did not live up to the
naked gun.
Oh,
well,
what was the movie?
What was the TV show that started naked
gun?
A police files or something?
Police squad and police squad.
Ninety three.
Wow.
Tombstone was 21 fucking years ago.
That's so crazy.
And when there another movie about a doc
holiday and all those guys that came out
at the same time,
you're
too close to it,
close to it,
but it was,
uh,
a little later.
And who was in it?
I want to say Kevin Costner.
I think so.
Yeah.
But tombstone was the good one with the
I'm your huckleberry and all that shit.
Here.
You Bitch.
Unforgiven no wrong.
And a dare you.
How dare you confuse Kevin Costner and
clinics would go back to Ohio.
You know,
Kevin Costner Played Wyatt earp,
right?
I think someone else played someone
like,
who else played it?
Kurt Russell was in there somewhere.
Maybe that's very confusing because I've
only seen tombstone Wyatt earp,
the movie,
let's see why it was good,
but it was weird because they had to,
um,
put Kevin Costner and some weird wig to
make them look like he was a kid and
then they took the wig off when he was
younger and you're like,
wait,
when he was older,
like,
wait a minute,
I was more of a young guns guy.
Young guns was fun.
It was 94.
So it was a year later.
Yeah.
So it was Kevin Costner and Dennis
Quaid.
Dennis Quaid Played Doc holiday.
He did a good job with doc holiday too.
But I remember this one dude who was an
actor.
I was trying to tell him,
I saw the movie,
I saw a tombstone.
I was talking about how good val kilmer
was as doc holiday.
I was like,
that dude was creepy.
Good in that movie.
He's like,
I disagree.
I thought it was.
Performance is a little over the top.
Um,
you know,
Dennis Quaid I thought did a much better
job in the Ra.
And I'm like,
no,
you don't go.
You don't think he just saw you saw him
do it.
You saw what Val kilmer did and you knew
that you can't do that and it bothers
the shit out of you because you're a
mediocre sitcom actor.
Yeah.
So you're all angry that Dennis Quaid
you like Dennis Quaid your hero.
Now you're going to let you go.
Because why?
Because Dennis Quaid did it.
It was.
It wasn't the same kind of performance.
That's a good job.
He did a good job.
But Val kilmer hit that creepy spot.
He hit that creepy spot where you really
believe he was a gunfighter.
You really believed that he had some
lightning reflex and he had killed 100
men with his gun when he was like,
I'm your huckleberry and he's got this
dead look in his eyes.
He,
that dude knew he couldn't hit that
spot.
Right?
And so he's like,
I thought it was performance was very
over the top,
the fuck you did over the top of my
ability.
Yeah,
exactly.
You just feel like shit when you watch
it.
Yeah.
So you try to diminish your hater,
hater face.
Okay.
The company Hookers,
do you think they had filming this?
None.
They're all kissing each other.
They'll fucking oil up after every show
around.
Smooched.
Charlie Sheen,
small mouth there.
Who are the lesser known guys?
Are they still working?
Isn't this Dr Mcdreamy or whatever his
name is?
Really?
Oh no,
that one's not.
Is one of the other ones.
Well,
why don't you find that the guy all the
way on the
right looks kind of familiar.
Here we go.
It's a million Esteban's.
Keep yourself and Lou diamond.
Phillips.
Charlie Sheen,
dermopathy,
Dermot,
Mulroney and Casey size.
None of those guys is Dr Mcdreamy.
Dr Mcdreamy.
That's women porn boy.
A doc.
Yeah.
Sensitive Dr.
good bone structure.
That's a woman porn and he's got good
ethics.
Dr Mcdreamy.
Guy From can't buy me.
Love.
Right.
[inaudible].
Patrick Dempsey.
Yeah,
I met that dude once at the comedy
store.
Yeah.
I got off.
I got off stage.
He's a nice guy.
Was a and uh,
he was with a,
a date I guess.
And um,
he's like,
man,
you really let that a heckler get here
just like a,
you know,
don't let them bother you that much.
So I said,
what?
No,
fuck him,
man,
you got shut those people down.
She was giving me advice on how to,
uh,
interact with hecklers,
not so dreamy.
I was like,
listen dude,
you get up there and you tell you tell
some jokes and have some drunk asshole
Yell Shit at you in front of a packed
house where you have to deal with that.
Like you don't know what that is.
Yeah,
you want to try it,
you go try it and then then tell me,
you know what it is.
But when someone's interrupting the flow
of the show,
like screaming shit out like you're
supposed to,
you have to deal with that and you got
to deal with that.
And as a producer of a way as possible,
you have to discourage that from ever
happening again.
And that's the only way to get comedy
out of it.
It's your job as a comedian to belittle
and mock that person.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It has to happen because the audience
feels that the audience has pissed.
You got a drunk eyes interrupting the
show.
It's almost always a guy,
but occasionally it's a check,
but they're less aggressive now.
The chicks that do it,
their heckles or very rarely like as out
and out.
Douchey is the men hackles.
They're more clueless right now.
Yeah.
They're not used to being told to be
quiet.
No,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Fuck.
You know,
in Boston I just let it happen.
Just let them pass.
There's no win in that.
You just Kinda have backup.
You have a lot of people with you.
Yeah.
I have like eight guys standing behind
you.
Right?
There's new club in Boston.
It just opened up like in the bottom of
a hotel.
It's one of those cool places where
there the clubs in the hotel.
You just.
Joey did that.
He said that it's very good club,
but the sound system sucks.
Oh,
well that's,
that's the only.
The most important part.
Yeah,
and they don't want to hear about it
apparently.
And people keep telling them the sound
system sucks.
They don't do anything about it.
They keep telling them through the
sound,
so I think joey was like,
fuck it,
I'm done.
But Joey could do the Wilbur theater
now.
Joe is gigantic now.
Joe Is the man.
Yeah,
he's too funny.
It's all working out.
He likes doing comedy clubs.
We all like doing comedy clubs.
But if joey wanted to,
if they didn't want to fix the sound
system,
he could easily do that.
The Boston comedy scene used to have
five clubs on one block and now they're
down to a theater and you know,
the outside rooms,
like the dicta already rooms.
He has a bunch of rooms.
I'm sure there's other people that book
rooms that I don't know about,
but the Intel clubs,
it's like they're down dike.
I think nick's does it only on weekends
and uh,
then they have this new place.
That's it.
Like the feet,
the scene just to the floor fell out of
it.
How long did you,
you started in Boston,
right?
Yeah.
And how many years were you there?
Um,
I was back and forth the third and
fourth year.
So I only really lived there for like
two and a half years while I was doing
comedy.
I may live there for longer.
I was born in New Jersey,
lived in San Francisco to allow as an 11
or a cow in New Jersey till seven San
Francisco,
seven to 11,
Florida,
11 to 13.
Boston 13 to like 24 ish.
That's when I moved to New York.
I was going back and forth the first,
um,
the first year I was doing a lot of,
it was hard to get gigs in New York.
I was a new guy.
Road gigs especially.
So I'd get road gigs in Connecticut.
I get some of them around Boston that
was like,
at least for the first,
like six months or so.
But uh,
it's uh,
it's fucking hard place now to make a,
make a living as a comment.
That's not the same thing anymore.
Yeah.
I've only,
I've never played an actual club they're
doing,
there's not that many.
There
used to be amazing.
It was.
I mean,
I wish I could,
I would.
I guess if I had realized how great it
was at the time of her,
I'd realized how,
how special it was.
Maybe I wouldn't have enjoyed it as
much.
Maybe like half of me enjoying it was
just being in the moment and then being
able to look back on it and go,
wow,
how lucky did I get?
Because I could've easily been somewhere
else.
I could have easily been in Miami.
I could it be I'm as a kid.
It wasn't my choice that we moved to
Boston.
I didn't have a say in it and the time
that I came onto the scene in August of
2000 or 1988 rather in August of 1988,
when I came on the scene,
I was 21 years old and the place was
just flooded with comedians.
There was all these like big name guys
were always in town.
There was always like billy crystal
would be in town and Robin Williams
would stop in and see these guys.
He had seen an hbo like Dom,
I rera was in town.
All these guys were in town and there
was a constant tour of like top level
talent that would come through Boston.
Like Hicks came through Boston Kennison
would come through Boston,
but he would do like theaters like down
the Cape,
so we'd go to the theaters and shit like
that and we saw them in Mansfield too,
but it was just an incredible time for
comedy,
like the greatest time ever to start,
but I think now it's getting pretty
close to that.
I think now might be out of all of the
years that I've been doing comedy,
there's more strong comedians now than I
think ever.
There's a lot because everyone knows
what everyone's up to on the Internet
and everyone is swinging for the fences
like everyone's really developed.
Yeah,
and I think
it's also easier for guys to get gigs
because they can get gay.
People can find out that you're funny
because of online you can get a
developer,
you can get a podcast,
develop a following,
and then start doing well in clubs and
people will come out to see you like way
easier than it would be to get a
television show which would give these
sort of the same kind of following when
you would go to clubs that that's what
you had to rely on 20 years ago.
Somebody will pick you to do something.
Now all you have to do is release your
CD online for free.
You know,
let everybody hear it.
People downloaded and they laugh and
then they find out that you're going to
be at a club next week.
I'll go see that guy.
He's hilarious.
And then boom,
you know,
and then you put little videos.
Go out little this little that a podcast
or did it today,
the full tron show.
Everybody knows who the fuck you are.
You know,
I love when networks out because it's
such a shitty process.
Everyone going through two or three
channels.
We'll think about all the guys that we
know now think about like Duncan Sigora,
Ra d as all those guys are going through
nontraditional channels.
They are and and I've known a lot of
times it was like a Hollywood wasn't
picking up on some of those guys 100
percent and now they're like doing way
better than a lot of guys that have tv
spots once because their nightclub
comics Hollywood's looking for
like even our.
And I had a conversation about that
recently about what it was like when he
first started out that he was always
worried that he wasn't doing something
that was going to get them on TV.
It was like it was,
was it a prison?
You would worry about doing tv or make a
TV set?
I have,
I have to have a TV set.
I have to be able to do censored
material.
But he also knew that if he was
uncensored and just himself and raw,
he could say hilarious shit and he could
kill.
He knew that he had that in him.
Yeah,
but it was like this struggle,
like how do you.
But how do you break through and make it
and then as he was developing,
right as he was developing the whole
Internet thing came along.
Yeah.
And he got into podcasts early,
I think
real early.
Yeah.
I mean that certainly helps,
but it's also just the amount of
material of his that's online now,
whether it's stand up or whether it's
him talking about shit.
He's got so much material now to like,
every time I see him he's doing like,
like what we're talking about,
he's going up on stage and he's doing
like a different 15 on the first show in
a different.
I'm talking about New York spots.
Uh,
he's always got like a.
he's got tons of material.
Hard
worker.
Yeah,
for sure.
Our,
he works hard.
He,
he gets things done.
He's a,
he's motivated and also he's motivated
because he's been,
he's been on the other side.
He's been the guy who tried to become a
comedian and was really struggling and
hating it.
And now that he's making it,
now that he's doing well and making
money,
he's really appreciating it.
Yeah.
I,
it's like,
I think what we're talking about,
like people that grow up in shitty
weather,
they're the ones who really appreciate
La.
Yeah.
You know,
and I think that when you struggle as a
comic,
everybody wants to get on American or
America's got talent like the first year
and start touring the nation and selling
out theaters was doing comedy in a year
and then I did mass square garden.
It was amazing.
No,
that's a nightmare.
You're going to die up there.
You know,
I've looked.
I've seen the bravest men ever.
And that's Charlie Murphy.
Charlie Murphy's the bravest man ever
when it comes to standup comedy because
Charlie Murphy was in his forties.
He had never done standup before and he
was on a hit television show and when he
was on Chappelle show,
he was telling these great stories and
everybody's like,
Holy Shit,
I want to see that guy to do comedy.
So they forced him into going and doing
like he would host and do like do,
do a little bit of time and then tell us
stories and people would laugh and then
all of a sudden he realized he was a
comedian.
Like,
okay,
now I'm a standup comedian.
He's going on the road and he's fucking
headlining.
Yeah.
Immediately,
immediately.
Forty five minutes a meat.
That is a long time.
Yeah.
That's so long.
It's so hard to do.
So many.
So many jumps you're going to have to
make to get to the top.
You're like,
there's people,
there's a mountain in the.
Most people are already like halfway up.
Right.
And you don't even have any clothes on.
Right?
You're going to try to do it out in the
open.
You got to be exposed and you get to try
to run up the mountain quick,
try to jump from base camp all the way
to the top of the mountain.
Dude's still in there swinging,
swinging.
It's incredible.
He's the bravest man in standup comedy.
I don't know.
A lot of people would have been able to
do that.
I couldn't.
He's got balls and he's fucking a good
dude,
man.
He's a very good dude.
Charlie Murphy.
He's a good dude.
I really enjoy that guy.
Enjoys company joy.
Being around him.
He's always,
always a fun guy to be around.
He's a very friendly guy too.
If you get to know him,
he's fucking hilarious.
I was with Maurice Smith and Ivan
salivary and Charlie Murphy is telling
us I'm old school karate fight stories
and we were dying laughing.
He was talking about hitting people with
Ridge hands.
It's a technique you don't see in ever
made the bridge hand Chicago Ridge hand
like I guess there's a Chicago Ridge
hand.
It's a type of karate chop that comes
from a specific angle,
but a lot of guys don't know about the
Chicago Ridge hand.
So the Murphy brothers were doing
karate.
Charlie was.
Charlie Murphy has a black belt,
I believe.
No kidding.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He knows a lot about martial arts.
Tell you that.
We had some conversations.
He knows a lot of shit.
He fought in a lot of tournaments and
stuff.
He's kind of a bad ass dude.
None of that.
Yeah.
Charlie Murphy is an interesting
character.
He's a very complex guy.
He's got a lot going on in his head.
I mean,
those guys who tell good stories,
they're homeless always very complex.
Right.
There's something about being that good
socially,
being that good of a storyteller,
that captivating,
that usually comes from a strange place.
Right.
It comes from Rick James.
I'm muddying up your couch.
Yeah.
Did that happen to him or Eddie?
That was the.
Both of them.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they were both there.
That is just one of the best stories of
all time.
I had Rick James on a show.
Uh,
I was doing this show for vh one,
I think it was,
was called the list and uh,
I think that was the name of it and uh,
it was,
um,
I had um,
a bunch of people on that were like
really famous,
like meatloaf was on one of my episodes
and Tom Sizemore was on one of my
episodes.
Got The leads.
Rob Halford one tiffany from.
I think we're,
yeah,
she was on one.
Um,
and uh,
that's hilarious.
Now that I'm thinking about that,
what was it called?
It was called the list.
Wow.
I totally forgot about that show.
And what happens on this show.
I don't remember.
Some non memorable sort of a trivia
show.
I don't remember.
TRACI lords was on one of them.
Nice.
TRACI lords post porn career when she
was legit actress.
Right.
She'd become a religion actress,
but who was the original person that we
were talking about was on it.
Charlie Murphy.
Charlie Murphy?
No,
no.
Rick James.
James.
Brick changes.
That's what it was.
He was defending Michael Jackson who was
one of the early Michael Jackson
controversies obviously before he died,
one of the earlier ones and Rick James
was a,
you know,
I know Michael.
I never seen that and there's other
woman was upset because she was a mother
and she was like,
you know,
like as a mom,
like,
that really freaks me out that he likes
sleeping with kids.
Oh,
you ain't got to worry.
He ain't doing nothing.
I know Michael for 20 years and Rick
James has something wrong with his
voice.
While he was there,
it was kind of fucked up.
Like something was wrong with his voice
and like had assistance with them and
the assistants were,
oh,
he's just got,
he's got a bit of a cold cut,
a bit of A.
Yeah.
And all I could think it's just.
See I could see him hitting that crack
pipe dude who do freebasing all night
and stumbling into that studio.
He was a real rock star man.
He had a bunch of people taking care of
them.
I was there,
bunch of people like cleaned him up and
polished them off.
Like had people that were moving them
around.
We were the fourth,
and this was,
um,
I,
I want to say this was before all the
chappelle stuff.
This was Rick James before.
I'm Rick James,
Bitch,
you know,
all that.
Which really sort of revitalized him
before his death.
That probably killed him probably.
Yeah.
It's probably Chappelle's.
I'm Rick James,
Bitch famous.
It become actually Rick James.
Cocaine is a hell of a drug.
Can bump everywhere.
Every time you're out,
all of a sudden it's like the seventies
all over again.
And you Rick James Again.
And the coke starts flowing.
Yeah.
Except if you don't got a young man's
heart and he had a 67 year old son,
he can't be smoking rocks with a 67 year
old heart.
No more cocaine,
no cocaine after 14 rule.
You know,
like I wrote this on twitter the other
day that at certain point in time it
becomes pathetic if you're drunk.
Right?
But if you hang in there around 70,
it gets cooler.
Right?
Like if you saw an old dude and he's
seven years old,
is a drunk on his front lawn,
he smoking a joint,
he's got a bottle of whiskey in his
hand.
You're like,
what's up man?
How you doing?
You want to give that guy a hug?
You know?
But if he was 50,
it's 50 and he's publicly drunk and
like,
oh listen man,
maybe you,
maybe you need to talk to your wife.
Sounds like you got a problem.
Yeah.
You know you guys fight.
I'm sorry man.
I gotta go.
I gotta go have a fucking bitch.
Man will tell you.
What she said to me is I was just
sending me,
no matter if seven years,
she said to me,
sir,
I hate to kick you off your own lawn,
but you got to go inside.
Come on,
Bro.
You 50 years old.
Shouldn't be drunk.
I like that.
It's kind of like a war veteran,
like type vibe once you're past 70 and
drinking and smoking.
Yeah.
I'm never going to tell a seven year old
guy to put away the cigarettes.
He's earned it,
but he's over.
It's over anyway.
Yeah,
just the last few days of the movie.
Just like your cigarettes.
Do whatever you gotta do.
Do it right.
I think you're absolutely right.
Brian's hanging in there.
He's like,
if I could just hang in there to 70,
30 more years to the 70 people,
the people who really want to believe
that cigarette smoking is okay.
They go,
well,
it all depends on the gene.
If you've got that gene,
you get the cancer,
but none of my family has cancer.
You know?
Knock on wood.
Absolve ation.
Yeah.
Not that many people have those jeans.
I don't know who does.
I think some people just survive somehow
or another that is smoking your lungs
every day.
Yeah,
it's a weird one.
It's a weird one,
man there.
I saw this thing the other day where
they were talking about,
um,
the vape pens and they were like,
these are clearly being marketed to
children.
Look,
this says strawberry bubblegum flavored.
Clearly this is marketed towards
children.
And I was gone.
I was watching that going,
what do you,
what?
Who pays you pays you to say this?
Well,
there's one way to look at it.
One would look at is say,
well maybe they really are concerned,
but they're just dumb.
Right?
You know,
and so they,
this was being marketed towards children
or adults that liked the taste of candy.
Is that even possible?
Candy with your tobacco?
I think it's pretty fucking possible
isn't absolutely.
So that's one.
Two clearly being marketed towards
children.
He magic.
We saw a kid with a vape pen and some
strawberry,
bubblegum flavored tobacco.
There's not an adult in the world there
will be like,
oh,
that's okay.
Strangers would like grab it out of his
hand.
Will that apparently,
that is a thing with young kids though.
Really?
They liked the vapor pens.
Kids that are trying to quit smoking.
Kids that started smoking at age 15 are
fucked.
Right.
That happens,
man.
No,
absolutely.
It happens.
I know someone whose kid is,
uh,
addicted to smoking and she's like 16 or
17 years old and they've tried to get
her off.
They've done this thing.
They've,
they took her to a rehab.
They took her to a hypnosis.
She can't get off.
Do you know if she
started with regular cigarettes or
electronic cigarettes?
Regular cigarettes.
My brother was always just like smoking
cigarettes when he was a kid,
like 11,
12.
My sisters started at 14.
And diesel smoke?
No,
she quit a while back,
but she smoked for a long time.
It's fucking she equipment.
She had kids when she was pregnant.
She quit.
It's dangerous shit,
man.
I mean,
it's amazing that someone would take you
having a baby to quit.
But my friend,
his mom,
he's got an older sister and his mom
quit smoking to have the older sister
and then just smoke through the
pregnancy with him.
She was like,
ah,
fuck it.
Oh my gosh.
He smoked for
let's move to the pregnancy.
Even though she knew how to quit.
Wow.
She's a nice lady.
I've met her.
That's an evil bitch,
bro.
Chill might say.
She's Nice Lady.
She cooked her kid.
Yeah,
she cooked that kid.
He's a.
he's a good friend of mine.
I'm sure that's probably what's wrong
with me.
My mom smoked while I was in the womb.
Yeah.
She did something wrong.
So good.
Yeah.
Remember my friend's mom smoke?
No,
I,
no one in my family smoked,
but my friend's mom smoked and she would
drive us to like the bowling alley or
whatever and it was just smoke in the
car.
I remember thinking as a kid,
like,
this is so gross.
I can't smell anything.
Separate.
Smoke out the windows.
Rolled up.
Cold Out.
Yeah.
And she's kind of smoking hack.
Hack with the heat on him.
I'll fucking drive your kids around,
but I'm not going to keep the air clean.
Yeah.
Well Greg Fitzsimmons is the best
stories.
His,
he lived in Boston and uh,
he,
his parents were chain smokers.
And so his mother and his father were
both chain smokers and they were in this
house,
like boxed in,
I think at the time actually was in New
York.
And then you said he lived in New York
for awhile too.
And uh,
he was just no air,
you know,
it's in the winter.
So the entire house was filled and he's
got asthma all the time.
So I'll fucked up.
Dad died young of a heart attack.
Dad didn't even make it to 60.
Just fuck.
I'm using that one.
The light.
Another one party rolling.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Who's that guy?
Keith Richards did happen.
I wonder what he smokes.
I wonder if we smoking Bama.
Love that.
Look how much younger he looked at in
that crazy.
Yeah.
That was like a week ago.
That dude aged more than any other
president.
He is stressed the fuck out.
I wonder what it is.
I've always wondered if it's stress or
if it's a lack of sleep or if it's.
They showed them where the aliens live.
I hope it's the latter.
That would be the best one or the third
one.
He knows too much about the alien agenda
that would keep you up at night.
Yeah.
That's why he plays along with the
rules.
He's like,
it doesn't matter.
Right?
The earth.
Do you want me to fucking know what's
behind the moon?
It's right there.
No,
but in all seriousness,
no one person should have a job that
does that to them.
I know a job that is everybody just in a
crazy way.
That's a great lesson.
The president is a great lesson for
people.
Yeah.
Like don't,
don't work that hard.
Right?
Look what happens to the president when
he works at heart.
Like you're going to burn that thing
out,
man.
And everybody's going for a second term.
Like everybody goes.
Anybody quit?
Does anybody ever get to four years ago?
You know what,
man?
Fuck this.
Not recently.
Not In the last 20 years.
Is it ever happened?
Let's find out.
I'm going to say a president has never
quit.
Okay.
I mean,
Richard Nixon was impeached.
The president ever reside.
What do you think,
Brian?
No,
I think Teddy Roosevelt did really?
And I said,
uh,
a physical issue.
You know,
I think he didn't want to hog it and
then he was bummed that he did it.
Richard Nixon,
that's it.
Richard Nixon resigned from office and
all he did was spy on people.
Yeah.
That's nothing.
No.
Weird.
So he did and he did things that they
were already doing.
Everybody was doing that.
There was spying on each other.
Everybody spies on each other back then,
but the public wasn't ready for that
shit right now.
Not My America.
Well,
it's kind of interesting,
but that's how like a lot of weirdness
went on with the CIA after the Nixon
administration got out of office.
Like that's when freedom of information
act was like all over the news.
It was a big issues.
And that's when they had this,
uh,
this nuclear submarine that was a
Russian nuclear submarine.
It's an issue of a or an episode of
Radio Lab,
which is one of my favorite podcasts.
And the what,
uh,
Glomar responses either Glo,
Mar.
It was a corporation,
global marine.
And they were responsIble for rescuing
this nuclear submarine.
They had a contract to pull this nuclear
submarine that the russians had lost
from the bottom of the ocean was like
seven mile thing,
crazy thing.
And so when the news got leaked and they
had to respond to the press,
they were being asked whether or not
they had this nuclear submarine in their
possession and they,
they knew because of the freedom of
information act that they had to give a
response they had to answer.
So the response was,
I can neither confirm nor deny.
Right?
And that's become something that people
say constantly.
I can neither confirm nor deny that mr
sheen was in that whorehouse.
brian was with this woman.
They,
when they do stuff like that,
that's called a glo mar response.
And then it all came out of this because
of the nixon administration's fuckups
because everybody was like aghast at
watergate and they wanted to acute,
told us you didn't do anything.
He lied.
We're going to get those layers.
We're going to go after those liars.
So that's,
uh,
that's where all that shit came from
until they got good at lying in.
Now that now they got it down.
I saw
a,
I don't know,
you've probably talked about jfk a lot
on this podcast,
right?
Or not.
Oh,
for sure.
I just sAw this recent thing on cnn and
it was all about like,
yeah,
oswald did it [inaudible].
I mean,
I always thought,
I always thought it was like this big
conspiracy and now we're back to oswald.
Did it.
The mainstream America version is that
oswald?
Did it.
I mean,
if you want to listen to,
uh,
most of the mainstream experts,
you know,
quote unquote,
that are on television,
they say oswald did it alone.
Yeah.
I don't think he did a loan.
I don't think it makes any sense.
Right.
but it's one of those things that you
really don't know unless you were there
and there's enough information back and
forth on both sides where the whole
thing gets incredibly sketchy.
Yeah.
I just saw those old,
I guess their pbs documentaries from the
eighties a and those just seems.
I don't know,
it just seemed like they had a lot of,
not evidence exactly,
but other people's perspectives and we
saw other people dressed as cops and
there might've been,
but the problem is one of the things
that they say about any experience when
something goes down,
like if some.
There was a crazy explosion right across
the street from us right now and you and
I just happened to be outside shooting
the shit podcast is over and the
building across the street from us
explodes.
We might have two completely different
stories as to what went down.
Right.
And if you compare those stories,
one of us might not have been paying
attention.
One of us mighT have a problem with the
truth.
One of us might want to exaggerate when
a camera's there.
One of us might want to make it seem
like he was a hero.
like it was way more terrifying that
he's actually been through something so
much more horrifying.
One of us might be the guy was a secret
information.
I saw a man run out of that car.
I witnessed it in evidence,
right?
Eye witness accounts are terrible.
They're really unreliable.
You ever talked to someone that you know
and you guys went through some weird
shit together and you go back and he
gives you a version of it and you
compare it to your version.
You're like,
one of us is fucking crazy.
Absolutely.
Because I don't.
I don't remember any of this shit you're
talking about.
Yeah,
that happens.
Yeah.
So when you,
when you hear about,
like people said they saw cops and
people said that,
that I,
I witnessed the cia give the thumbs up
and then the shooting started,
right?
I was there.
Yeah.
Maybe you were,
but maybe you're just making a bunch of
shit up,
right?
Memories a terrible dude.
absolutely.
They're awful.
I know.
But if you look at the evidence,
tough to shoot someone three times that,
that accurately from a,
from a window with a rifle that has a
shitty scope,
but it is possible.
Everybody says not possible.
It's possible.
The real problem is the impacts on the
body.
The magic bullet theory that went
through one body.
it's not magic.
So you're just confused about the.
I've seen it all.
What's magic is the bullet hit bones,
shatteRed bones,
and came out looking like that.
That looks like a bullet that got shot
into a swimming pool.
And anybody who tells you any
differently is not being honest.
That seems weird.
Is it possible that the bone was
shattered by that bullet and it came out
looking like that?
It's very unlikely.
Very,
very unlikely.
It might be possible.
I mean in the freakiest of freaky
circumstances.
But when bullets hit things,
they fuck up.
They twist up,
they bend.
Just what happens.
Um,
you know,
there's stronger bullets than other
ones.
Full metal jacket,
bullets like that one a little bit
stronger.
But you're talking about like a bullet
that left fragments and people's bodies
to.
It wasn't as simple as the bullet got
through shattered bone cleanly and fell
onto that.
No,
it left little pieces of metal pieces of
metal that aren't actually missing from
the bowl that they found.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's screwy.
Yeah.
It's the scrooge story and it's a story
that they,
they wanted that guy dead.
Everybody wanted that guy dead.
There was a bunch of people that wanted
that guy dead.
it wasn't a.
It wasn't hard to imagine someone
plotted to murder him.
Right.
It seems pretty likely that someone
wanted to murder him and I don't think
it's likely that oswald wanted to do it.
Right.
You know,
I think it's way more likely that some
of these incredibly powerful groups that
would profit off of him being dead would
want him dead.
And I think back then in 1969,
19,
63 is it were you,
you weren't at accountable,
man,
you can get away with shit.
Right.
But I also think that people like to tie
up history with a nice neat little bow.
You know,
you know what?
Forget all your conspiracy shenanigans.
Oswaldo acted alone.
It was a weird news program.
It was on cnn and it was very much like.
It was very much like,
come on.
Yeah,
it was a as well where like two hours
straight.
I would like to see someone who knows a
lot about the case,
debate them,
not me,
but someone who actually knows a lot
about the case,
debate them,
you know,
my take is that it's not an either or.
You know,
when everyone oswald did this,
oswaldo did that.
Oswald did it,
or oswald was a part of it.
That's possible as well.
And that's one thing that people aren't
considering.
The idea that oswald got killed because
he knew too much.
He was going to expose it.
Well,
it could have been the he got killed
because look,
they arrested him.
If we kill him then they're not even
going to know about all the other
shooters,
but if they hold that guy and start
interrogating him and he starts telling
about the entire plan and then someone
gets in trouble.
So what do they do?
They murder him in front of a bunch of
cops.
Yeah.
They had a guy with mob ties do it.
Right.
Hilarious.
The whole,
the whole thing stinks.
And anybody who pretends it doesn't
stink.
You're just trying to put like a neat
little bow on it and be the guy who's
not a your unknown nonsense guy.
I know that I'm a no nonsense guy.
Okay?
We both know kevin has walled,
acted alone.
Come end of story.
Am I right?
Jesus is fucking hippies.
They want it.
They'll believe anything.
Lee harvey oswald.
I don't know,
man.
I just know that that's a.
It's a crazy thing that they can kill
the president.
It is,
And if they did get away with it,
if there is a group of people,
whether it's the cia or the fbi or the
fucking mob or whoever it was,
if someone did get away with killing the
president,
that's incredible.
It's insane.
You know?
Well,
people can't keep secrets.
That's proven fact.
There's no way.
That's the number one reason why you
should think that because people can't
keep secrets.
People will always kept sacred.
I think I'd be able to keep a secret
that would put me in jail.
People are pretty good at keeping
secrets.
Anybody who says that people are bad at
keeping secrets just is not taking into
account how many fucking secrets there
really are that they don't know about.
What you're seeing is the shitty
secrets.
You know when you,
when you see someone get busted for
something where were seen as a bunch of
weak,
weak john bitches flapping off at the
gums and ruin in there.
Perfect situation.
yeah,
that's what.
That's what you're saying.
But another group might be able to dress
up like an hour.
God sacrifice a hooker light on fire.
Go back to work at the mall and give
each other the little owl sign.
Fucking make their way to the bathroom
passing away and he might keep that day
they die.
Yeah.
It might be fun for them like being a
mason or something.
Yeah.
Fight club.
Yeah,
jihadist.
That's definitely something too.
It's a radical life,
you know,
giving sacrifices,
but you're doing it for a law about that
blown up bitches.
Yeah.
Making it real.
Keeping chicks from driving,
keeping chicks from being seen.
Yeah.
Cover up,
cover up and no driving.
Don,
my religion says so my religions as so
I sat next to two women on a.
I've took a greyhound bus for the first
time over my midwest animal.
Why'd you do that?
Because the budget was dwindling and I
needed to get back to cleveland.
That's real and so I took the greyhound
and sitting next to me were two women in
burkas and it was hot and it didn't
smell good.
Oh,
it was hot out.
It wasn't sexy.
It was sexy.
There's a little bit of sexiness to it,
but there's something to do it.
It's like,
let's make a deal.
It was like,
what's going on under that?
It would be great.
It would be great if they were hot and
they were just into doing it because
they only one in the show themselves for
their man.
Yeah.
If it was their idea,
yeah,
that'd be kinda cool.
Right.
that would be kind of wild.
If you dated a chick and she just
started showing up.
she showed up with a itch hot as fuck.
She wear a burka and you're like,
why are you wearing a burqa?
I don't want anybody to see me,
but you.
Oh my god.
It'd be like,
whoa,
that's crazy.
That's pretty hot.
That's an intense.
But that's also a chick who will burn
your fucking hold town down in hopes of
killing you when you break up with her.
she loves you.
She'll fucking set a gas leak in your
town slowly in the middle of that.
I should plan it out in advance.
Yeah,
that sounds like a crazy bitch.
But whoever the guy was at first
invented the burka.
What a hater.
Steve burke.
What a bitch.
That guys are cock blocker.
Yeah.
That guy is the worst pimp hand ever.
Pimp pants a week.
He has to cover his chicks up.
Come on up so much.
You're looking at like this.
This is it.
everything else.
Cloth.
So heartbreaking.
What's a big part of the world?
You know,
it's not like 20 people are doing it and
it's hard to get rid of the psychology.
Oh,
it's impossible,
right?
Yeah,
man.
Bum you out.
You want to rescue those chicks?
It does bum me out,
but I think they're past the point of
being rescued.
Do you?
Never know they might want to put the
effort in,
but if I could do it like that,
then I mean it kinda just bums me out.
If you could take them to the amazon.
Yeah.
Show them the dragon,
taken for a ride and then immediately
bring them back and sort of reinvigorate
them back into society.
Yeah.
Do it.
He would do it.
If it took like maybe a week or two.
I'm not going to dedicate my life.
You should offer that as a service.
I should.
The full charge.
that's what you call it.
I'm a comedian,
podcaster and burqa.
Liberate.
Yeah.
Burka liberate.
Or I like it,
dude.
He just take these arab chicks not
having a good go of it.
How's your passport ladies?
How is it fresh?
Is it ready for a peruse stamp chunk?
Now you're naked.
Yeah.
Next thing you know you're partying with
the full charge.
They'd probably never drank before.
So what to do with that shit?
We traveled by grey hounds.
Yeah.
That would be rude to try to get someone
drunk for the first time once you've
liberated them for their burqa.
Yeah,
that's.
You don't have that kind of experience.
You can't just drink,
drink,
and party when you've been wearing a
burka your whole life.
No.
Reading off some ancient texts can't do
it.
how long has it been around?
If you had to guess?
if I had to guess.
I would say it's been around for fuck
over 2000 years,
but I really don't know.
Alright.
We're gonna.
Find out.
I'm going to say I'm going to say you're
right.
As the burka.
After a.
Before gbc.
My,
my history in bc is very fuzzy.
Alright,
here we go.
I'm in a diy kind of guy.
Face veiling portion is usually a
rectangular piece of semi-transparent
cloth with this top edge attached to a
portion of the headscarf.
Okay.
When did it come from islamic texts?
The quran has no requirement that women
covered their faces with a veil or cover
their bodies with the full body berko.
That's near my burka,
the full body burchell buddy.
It's called a chador.
It's not in the koran.
Many muslims believe that the collective
traditions of the life of mohammed or
hadith required both men and women to
dress and behave in public.
However,
thiS requirement has been interpreted in
many different ways by islamic scholars
and muslim communities.
Some interpretation say that avail is
not a compulsory is not compulsory or
that it's not compulsory in front of
blind men,
a sexual men or gay men,
but gay men are allowed to either a
bunch of.
I don't know.
Yeah.
You're supposed to get rid of them,
right?
They're supposed to hit them with rocks.
Very strange.
say what you want about America.
Yeah.
well,
the real problem is when we were talking
about before,
a lot of these areas they've been.
They've been lIving like this for a long
time.
Yeah.
It's.
It's hard to get out of that.
It's hard to snap that,
stop that culture dead in his tracks and
try to figure out a better way to live
your lives and to do it in a way that is
completely alien to thousands and
thousands of years of tradition.
That's the thing,
like you've got to come up with these
ideas by yourself and you've got to
figure out how to get away from it when
no one's there to help you.
I assume,
listen to this and say to the faithful
woman to lower their gaze and guard
their private parts and not to display
their beauty,
except when except what is apparent of
it except what is a parent of it,
and to extend their head coverings to
cover their bosoms and not to display
their beauty except to their husbands or
their fathers or their husbands,
fathers or their sons or their husbands,
sons or their brothers or their
brothers,
sons or their sister's sons or their
women folk or what their right hands
rule.
WhetheR tennis instructor leaves their
slaves nice.
Or the followers from the men who do not
feel sexual desire.
What the followers from the men who do
not feel sexual desire or small children
to whom the nakedness of women is not a
parent,
and not to strike their feet on the
ground so as to make known what they
hide of their adornments.
Strike their feet on the ground.
So their tits jiggle,
they're saying don't make your ass and
tits jiggle chicks were working in the
old days.
This is an anti twerking passage in the
koran.
That's where it all starts.
That's what they're saying.
That's where civilization don't stomp
your feet on the ground as to make known
what they hide of their adornments.
Whoa man.
That's deep.
Yeah.
Depresses me,
man.
Does it.
Well,
didn't you just read that?
It's not reAlly part of the koran.
No,
no it's not.
Which is always.
Some muslim societies don't,
uh,
don't use it.
So that happens all the time.
Like religions will just adopt an idea.
Like there's a lot of christians that
like going to war,
that type of thing.
Well there's all sorts of weird
interpretations of old languages too.
That's what things gets kind of
squirrely when you're reading some shit.
There was something that's 2000 old or
even
more,
I mean the context,
like trying to put it in context,
trying to figure out what life was like
back then and why are they smarter than
us?
Why are we looking to them?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
I feel like we're smarter than them yet.
Dah,
dah.
Thinking again.
Yeah,
but you know what it is,
man.
We like old shit.
We do.
We love old shit.
Yeah.
We're doing this because our forefathers
did this.
We'd love the ancient texts.
Yeah,
ancient wisdom and ancient scholars.
People love that.
They love it.
They can find something from the past
that was forgotten.
The ancient scholars knew all about
life.
The origins of the universe.
Like when we find something on the wall
of some sort of a temple in Iraq,
it's thousands of years old and it's the
solar system.
people freak out.
This is amazing.
Look at the knowledge they had like my
six year old draws solar systems that
good.
I'm not joking.
Right?
They dropped.
She drew the sun,
jupiter and earth.
She copied it off of a book,
but my what?
My point is like,
that's a shitty solar system,
right?
That was 6,000
years ago.
Of course our solar systems.
But have you ever watched cosmos?
You fuck.
Okay.
Our version of the solar system is way
better than that old dumb shit cart.
Yeah.
It's impressive that they did this.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yes.
It's fascinating.
It's a historically enriching that we
could look at this stuff and you mean
it's a trip you go.
have you ever been to like,
uh,
the natural history museum and checked
out some ancient egyptian artifacts?
it's fascinating.
And fantastic.
King tut baby.
Fuck yeah.
That's fascinating.
You get to look at something that was
made thousands of years ago.
People that just lived a completely
different way than you.
It's humbling.
And fonzie's jacket.
Fonzie's jacket.
No,
that's all at the dc dc museums.
They really have fonzie.
Fonzie jacket.
Credibly.
Puffy shirt.
Fonzie jackets.
Tiny.
Yeah.
How tall is henry winkler?
I don't know.
I,
I had a picture with hiM.
I took a picture with him.
He'S a great guy.
he was on that show.
Uh,
one of the movies that I did with Kevin
James.
Here comes the boom.
He was the teacher.
Yeah.
Great guy.
He's so nice.
Yeah,
it seems like henry winkler is one of
the nicest people I've ever met.
He's just genuinely openly nice and
friendly and he,
he loves to fly fish.
He loves to go out and fly fish on
rivers and stuff and he wrote a book
about it called never met an idiot on
the river.
Yeah.
Probably got really lucky if that's the
case.
It's a lot of fucking idiots on the
river.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.
How often do you do those tours where
you go out for lIke three weeks like
that?
Not often.
I,
I've been doing recently because I've
been a opening for christ.
You're doing split weeks and I kinda got
to like do a tour to make them work,
you know,
and then I try to hit stuff in between
and then I'll do a throw in like a
headlining thing.
It just doesn't make a lot of sense to
come all the way back to la,
but I'm kinda over that because it's
just not that much fun and it wears you
down.
I mean the chrysler parts are fun.
The crusher,
you know what I mean?
When you go on the road for three weeks
is hard as fuck when I'm just chilling
in valley park,
Missouri and like 15 people are showing
up at night.
It's horrible.
It was.
Where are we doing the coMedy store in
Missouri?
Saturday night was good,
But so two shows were great and then the
other four were just like that comedy
store,
original room style of comedy.
Could you do like thursday through
sunday and I went.
You did the third thursday through
sunday.
wow.
it's so funny too because I only have
like a couple of fans so actual fans
will come up to see me do.
Shell is in front of 15 people,
you know?
That's got to be weird,
but it is with them.
It's got to be cool as fuck though
because look,
they're a little concerned.
They shouldn't.
They should look at it this way.
You're funny.
Talented and it's just a matter of
people knowing about it.
So they,
they get into the ground floor,
they get mad street credit.
Right.
They dope deal with there.
I saw richard jenny perform in front of
a very small crowd at catch a rising
star on like a wednesday night one night
in boston.
I'll never forget that.
There was half full audience,
you know,
it was like nobody knew who he was back
then,
but I was like,
wow,
this is amazing,
you know,
so they got to see you when you eat and
shit.
And I am,
I am.
I'm half joking.
Like could the shows were actually all
really fun.
They were just like before the show
started,
it's like 15 people.
here we go.
and that was the whole audience.
15 people some nights.
Yeah,
it could get up to 20 and I think the
good nights kick get up.
It was too good.
Shows with about 50,
60 people and those were like a lot of
fun,
especially compared to the smaller
shows.
But it was never horrible because they
did laugh,
you know what I mean?
But you're funny and that's the hardest
thing to do,
so all matters from here on out is just
you just keep doing it.
You just keep doing it.
There'll be able to laugh one day.
Sure.
There'll be able to say,
I saw you in front of 15 people right in
Nebraska.
Yeah.
And you'd be like,
I remember that chat.
This club was kind of ghetto like after
my first show on thursday,
two people walked into the back alley
and started screwing up against the
dumpster.
That staff found lace.
Yeah.
That's how you do it.
Yeah,
but I mean that only goes to show you
how inspiring I am as a comic.
You know what I mean?
Fuck,
it's true.
Make people horny.
A lot of people killed bonus with their
comedy.
Yeah,
exactly.
Excited them.
Not me.
I make it sexy.
Where was this?
What club?
Valley park,
Missouri.
Funny bone.
It's only been open since like october.
Is it?
Is there A chain of funny bones or do
they buy the name?
How does that work?
Because it seemed to be independent.
I don't fully understand it.
There's people that own.
There's one guy that owns a bunch and
then I think it's like a franchise you
can kind of buy in or something.
Like.
What about the funny bone of columbus?
that's a.
That's a guy named dave strube.
There's a lot of those.
Oh,
he owns more than one of those.
He's a good dude.
Yeah,
absolutely worked for that many times.
Yep.
That clubs great,
funny columbus places.
Great.
Or they just remodeled it.
It also.
Why would they do that was perfect.
I didn't.
I think they did somethiNg like they
just made it bigger.
That was always kind of weird.
They never really had a green room.
That's bad.
That's the,
that's weird.
You have to go to dave's office and hang
out,
but whatever.
You're in columbus,
Ohio,
you can get all high flutent.
What are you kinda gotta deal with what
you've got to deal with.
But um,
uh,
I'm doing,
austin coming up soon.
I'm doing cap city.
Yeah,
because I'm getting ready to do my
comedy special.
Some doing a week at the club.
They painted over all the.
What's wrong with them?
So that was history.
I think the full charge wasn't fucking
written up there because it was,
I'm sure it was just some paint now.
Yeah.
That was history that the wall was
covered in history and they decided to
make it pretty.
They.
Whoever did it was just a boner killer.
I don't know who did that.
Whoever you are out there,
you know who you are.
Yeah.
Whoever gave it the green light,
whoever whose ever idea it was atlanta.
Punchlines still got it.
My favorite one,
I think we talked about this.
My favorite thing was right in front of
the toilet.
It said,
keep the toilet seat up so maybe it will
make women not wanting to do comedy it
or something like that.
Keep women out of comedy.
The best is the atlanta punchline that
that back room still has writing
everywhere.
I haven't been there.
I'm going there and never did it.
I'm going there in august.
I think you've never done it.
Never done it.
Ooh.
It's a classic.
It's one of the best clubs.
Awesome.
It's a real,
real legit,
awesome club.
Old school is.
Fuck you.
Look on the wall.
You see like an old barry sobel picture.
You know one of those.
Love that shit.
Kenny rogers photo xannies in nashville
will not take down the old headshot and
they shouldn't.
No,
Xannies in nashville is another one.
That's another classic spot,
but on the back room of the atlanta
punchline says,
quit trying to be hicks.
Ah ha ha.
that was so appropriate to at the time.
Yeah.
oh dude.
Everyone I knew try to be hicks.
Yeah.
And I mean we all got caught up in it,
like I went to,
like to open mics and somebody actually
handed me a tape with bill hicks on it.
It was woody allen and bill hicks,
you know,
once I was bill hicks side was woody
allen,
what did you like better?
Uh,
I definitely like bill hicks better.
I listened to this thing at the time and
probably still do.
I'm not sure does.
Do you take off any points because woody
allen's a perv no,
not for that.
I assume it wasn't that much prefer back
then.
That doesn't actually bother me.
Not as much as a woman in a burka.
It does bother me,
but I still kinda like to watch his
movies.
A good movie maker.
Yeah.
So I,
I guess,
but I think that's kinda fucked up.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
there's a picture of him at the
basketball game when
his daughter was young and she sitting
on his lap and she's really little and
then there's a picture of him at the
basketball game many years later and
they're holding hands as a couple.
so weird and it's just,
whoa.
I don't think that's okay at all.
I really don't.
That's deep that,
that is a completely different kind of
experience that's deep.
Like you,
you were there when that thing,
that thing,
that person was a baby,
you know,
when a little child,
I don't know.
You don't know?
And I dunno,
I dunno.
I choose not to speculate.
Yeah,
watched a,
I'm a,
I'm not callous about it.
I just,
you know,
obviously I denounce it.
I'll say that it's gross,
but I don't,
I don't know any of the particulars.
Yeah.
I barely paid attention to that whole
case.
I just don't like to.
Whenever I see people in those sort of
terrifying situations,
the man,
the women's splitting up the man going
after the girl's daughter and they're
together now and like,
oh,
a fucking crazy pain.
But I was listening to a thing of the
day,
I didn't know it was an interview,
I thought it was woody allen's comedy
and I downloaded it and it Was,
um,
it was woody allen talking about standup
and it was him talking about all of the,
um,
the different kinds of a joke writers
and different.
And this is a long ass fucking time ago.
And it was really kind of interesting,
man.
It was,
um,
it was really interesting to listen to
him from like,
gosh,
I don't know.
I mean if I had to guess,
I'd say it was probably like the 19
fifties or something like that.
And he's talking about comedy.
If I had to guess by the references that
he was using,
maybe the sixties,
but he's talking about standup and he's
talking about,
you know,
different.
And a lot of the shit that he was saying
back then still holds true today.
Yeah.
I think he was part of that like kinda
hipster original alt room comedy.
Like they just used to do it at
makeshift places in the village and not
necessarily clubs or comedy clubs are
strip clubs or however,
whatever it was.
Trisha traditional back then.
Yeah.
Isn't that wild?
Like they would do it.
They would do it in,
like they would open for people to like
for bands and stuff like that.
That would do stand up.
yeah.
And they just do it in coffee shops and
stuff.
It's really weird because the con,
the standup comedy that we know today
really started in the seventies,
right?
Um,
maybe the sixties,
sixties.
Well it was lenny bruce really?
RigHt.
That's the number one.
That's the first seed.
I think there was a bunch of other guys
like that.
There was sort of in that vein at the
time that were coming along with him
back and forth.
But he Was the original.
Yeah.
And there's even like old rodney
dangerfield where he tries to do like a,
a,
a lenny bruce style where like,
it's a big long story and it's like,
you know,
rodney dangerfield is known for one
liners.
Yeah.
He used to do these really long form
jokes about like getting his car fixed
and riding in an airplane in
a woody allen on comedy is the name of
it.
It's available on amazon if anybody
wants to get it.
It's just a 10 different things.
10 different short little clips that
they have broken up into segments on a
different,
different topics.
Really.
Interesting.
Really interesting.
I've alWays been fascinated by the
writing style.
You know,
everybody's got their own sort of style
and I'm also fascinated by how few
people actually.
Right,
right.
And you find out that there's a lot of
comics that don't actually sit down and
write a whole essay.
You can't fake it for an hour body to
sit down with some coffee and scribble
lazy pitch.
You have the opportunity to be a
professional comedian.
You've actually figured out a way to
make it through that.
You're not even writing anything down.
It's crazy.
Oh,
silly.
Because even if you write all the time
and you record a lot of your thoughts
and stuff,
there's still so few,
so little amount of material that makes
it to the stage.
Yeah.
So like if you're doing nothing and
nothing's happening,
well that's those guys that you run into
10 years later and they're doing the
same act and you're like,
oh,
you poor bastard,
you poor bastard.
It's not even changed,
like not even two minutes of it as
different nominees.
So scary sometimes that sometimes you
just get a little life raft of an act
and you just want to sit on it and just
wait because that,
that,
that new joke.
It's a painful thing.
That's why it's an awesome growth
process to do it the way he does it or
does it or louis ck does it to do it
that way.
And abandoned ship.
Yeah.
Imagine if bands had to do that every
year.
They abandoned ship.
Yeah.
No,
they'd be in trouble because they got to
play the hits.
Fuck,
that's for sure.
That's a difference between comedy and
music.
Yeah.
The only one who got to play the hits
and comedy was dice.
Yeah.
I heard rodney got to play the hits.
Yeah,
I bet.
That's what I heard.
I forget where I heard that,
but I believe different times though,
that was a different era.
You know?
You ever see rodney live?
Never.
I used one of my favorites.
I got to see him a few times.
I got to see him late in life too.
I got to see him at the laugh factory.
Like real late.
Yeah.
He was like in his sixties,
hanging out with some 40 year old chick.
Yeah.
they're still partying.
Right?
That's a good buck a month.
Oh.
I always think it's really funny that
when I was a kid in the eighties,
I wasn't heavily into rodney
dangerfield,
but I go see his movies,
which is weird.
like what 11 year olds are going to see
movies about 60 year olds now and
laughing.
That's really weird.
So true.
That's a great way of puttiNg it,
but he was also something someone that
everybody loved.
Yeah.
Like you didn't think of roddy is like
an old guy.
Definitely not.
Yeah.
You would think of other old guys is
like old guys.
Yeah.
He's like the coolest guy in back to
school.
He's the coolest guy in the movie as the
oldest guy in the movie.
Yeah.
who is this romantic interest?
Remember was the woman that does like
the true hidden valley commercials.
That's right.
Yeah.
She's a professor.
She was in meatballs three.
How old was she at the time?
Dangerfield.
Like 60.
If you had to guess.
She must have been somewhere around 50.
Maybe a lIttle younger.
Really.
I don't know.
I have a hard time with that because I
found it very attractive.
How attractive.
Like you bust a move.
Yeah,
I think I would really.
I think I would.
What's your age limit?
You would cut a check off that I think.
I think around 55.
Whoa.
You're a generous man.
I mean it all depends.
It all depends on if she goes to yoga.
There's,
there's some good looking 55 out there
are now.
Yeah,
there are now.
yeah.
And scientific.
Have you seen christie brinkley?
Yes.
And that's exactly the type of thing I'm
talking about.
The old christie brinkley now she's up
there.
She's taught as fuck.
You seen Helen Hunt lately?
No.
I don't need to do that.
There's this movie called what?
He's trying to kill my boner,
talking to bring it up.
Helen hunt.
You're going the wrong way,
but you got to hear this picture,
chrissy buggy to cleanse my palette.
Let's take this conversation slow.
There was,
this is getting exciting.
There was this movie called the session
and if you just look up the preview of
it,
it's about this guy that has an iron
lung and he's,
you know,
he's very like stephen hawking and then
maybe just laying there going,
oh,
you know like and stuff.
And so helen hunt's like his therapist
or something and he goes,
she's like,
ah,
you need to get laid.
So she starts taking off her clothes and
you see her full bush,
her body.
What movie is this?
It's called the session.
Is this an old movie?
Oh,
this came out like two years ago and
it's just Helen Hunt fucking this
retarded.
Get retarded.
This iron lung guy and it's just creepy
as fuck.
It's just a creepy version of Helen
Hunt.
Her face looks weird,
like,
okay,
and then you just see her bush and she's
having sex through the whole movie.
pull up that picture.
Sounds pretty good.
Great.
christie?
Christie brinkley,
bitch.
Disgusting me.
That's.
Yeah,
that's current.
Okay,
and she's got to be how old?
She's old her throat though.
Whatever.
Whatever it is to throw a little tuck.
This validates my nowhere.
Scarf get her into horse riding.
I would make her drive in a convertible
and chase me around while I drove in a
station wagon
up town.
Girl.
Well,
if you compare the way she looks today
and the way she looked when she was with
billy joel,
not that difference.
Compare the way billy joel looks today
and the way billy joel looked when he
was with christie brinkley.
I think she's a vampire.
She stole his soul.
Do you think this threat things caused
by cock?
Just tOns of and no,
bro.
Your skin gets bad.
She's a $60.
Most likely.
She's 60 years Old.
Don't you?
Can't.
You don't respond to them with.
That's amazing.
She looks fantastic.
Absolutely.
That's as good as a 60 year old woman
has ever looked in the history of the
world and that's what I mean.
We're talking about exceptions.
When I say,
yeah,
you're not looking at her and going,
oh,
she looks good for 60.
You're looking at her and goes,
damn,
she looks really good.
She's hot,
she's hot,
and her body's really nIce too.
Yeah.
Kristy full chevron,
kapow,
kapow.
I'll take it.
I'll take it all day.
Yeah.
You make out with her.
I'll check that throat cutter.
It's.
It's not that bad dude or throw.
It doesn't look bad.
You're focusing on the wrong thing.
What do you.
You got to mirror bitch.
You're going to be very focused on that.
Throat gutters.
Weird.
Yeah.
It ain't that bad,
dude.
Come on.
She's hot as fuck.
You're out of your mind.
You look at their neck.
You're looking at a still image just for
neck.
A little brian.
That's nothing.
You're saying nothing.
You're making noise with your face.
You really frustrating me right now,
brian.
Yeah.
There's nothing going on with what
you're saying.
You just fixating on next.
Next,
get a lot worse.
Speaking in next,
there's a video that I tweeted today.
It's fucking hilarious.
It's some climate change denier lady and
uh,
it's,
she's got a weird neck.
Look at the picture,
look at the picture on my twitter and
you'll see what I'm talking about,
but it's the one of the dumbest Climate
chaNge deNial videos I've ever seen in
my life.
For whatever reason,
I don't know what this is,
but there's a lot of like I'm down home
country type people to want to tell you.
Climate change is a myth as well.
This is her.
See,
look at that.
Compare her neck to christie brinkley's
nag.
I'll take christie brinkley's nap all
day,
but play the play the video because it's
quite hilarious.
It's so strange in fact,
that it's,
it's hard to believe that there's a lot
of people like that,
but she's going on about cold climate
change.
Kalama change is a myth.
Why are you so upset in my announcements
for congress here in Louisiana?
Progress.
It's
something very provocative.
I said that global warming is a hoax.
Naturally liberals in the lame stream
media became unglued and attacked me in
media,
but it's geOrge orwell wrote,
and that's why I'm of universal deceit
telling the truth is a revolutionary
act.
A specter is haunting America.
It is perhaps the greatest introduction
into the history.
It has been almost 10 years since failed
presidential candidate al gore put out
his propaganda film the inconvenient
truth,
proclaiming that the actions of
america's energy industry are causing a
catastrophic rise in the earth's
temperature,
quite inconveniently for al gore and for
the rest of the politicians who continue
to advance this delusion.
Any 10 year old can invalidate their
thesis with one of the simplest
scientific devices known to me,
a thermometer,
they get colder each year since the
film's release.
God certainly has a wonderful sense of
irony.
President obama knows it's getting
colder,
was blame our recent economic growth on
record freezing weather,
and then he turned around and launched a
new debate on global warming and the
obama administration down is up.
Two plus two equals five,
and ignorance is strength.
Last summer and article reached the
coldest temperature in recorded history.
There's record,
she eyes and a 60 percent rise of ice in
the arctic.
See,
polar bears have been forced out of
their habitat because of overpopulation.
Liberals for vas that global warming
would cause an increase in severe
weather systems such as hurricanes,
and they blamed global warming every
time these dangerous storms take place.
The experts agree over the last several
years.
Storms have decreased.
Perhaps the biggest clue that this is
one big scam.
We swept under the rug by the lapdog
medium.
A computer hacker obtained access to the
mail server at the climate research
center of east anglia in the uk and
downloaded over 1000 emails proving
without a shadow of a doubt that these
so called scientists had falsified data.
That conspiracy of global warming has
had a devastating effect on the american
dream.
The rise of modern society since the
first refinement of crude oil in 18,
47 is no coincidence.
America's energy producers have fueled
the industrial revolution,
which caused never before seen advances
in living standards for the masses of
ordinary people.
It was the burning of oil that energized
the foundation of a real middle class.
In the 20th century,
giving them access to new luxuries such
as electric lights,
refrigeration and automobiles,
it was free market capitalism that
created the wealthiest society the earth
had ever seen,
but now both capitalism and our energy
industry are under attack and the hopes
of global for dad.
It's exhausting.
What the fuck you imagine if you had
that check over for a dinner party,
she just keeps.
She started hitting you with that garden
and she's reading off fucking cute cards
because that did not sound like her
idea.
She was reading.
Well,
it might've been her ideas,
but she was definitely reading something
that was written out in advance.
I do notice,
and this is like total nitpicking,
but they're quoting this movie.
They're shitting on this movie an
inconvenient truth.
Right?
They got the title wrong.
What is it?
They said the inconvenient truth,
and I know I'm nitpicking,
but like if that's your main argument,
like you'd still.
It's weird that they're not going,
they're not looking it up.
Well,
I have a theory.
What's that?
I think she's dumb as fuck.
Yeah,
for sure.
And that was the best fuck but not
available.
Right?
That was the best take they got.
So fuck it.
It's the inconvenient truth.
Dumb as fuck.
But not,
not uh,
not,
not available,
not aware.
No.
She's dumb as fuck.
Right?
Like probably thinks she's pretty smart.
Absolutely.
God has a wonderful sense of humor.
Like a thermometer.
I like women.
Obama was stressed out about the cold.
Yeah.
He's very stressed out.
He gets dressed out.
It's getting cold every year and he
knows it.
Yeah.
Picture of him.
Obama knows it.
Right?
And,
and again,
I love how they,
like they throw back to 100 years ago
and they go,
look,
this worked 100 years ago.
Man.
What's the problem?
The reason why ordinary people it raised
the life standard for ordinary people.
Ordinary people.
What's an ordinary?
What's an ordinary person?
Ordinary.
Like she's like making a plea towards
the ordinary.
Yeah.
Plead,
plead towards the mediocre,
like me.
Mediocre small minded people with shitty
synopses like myself.
Yeah.
Regular americans anymore that bitches
running for congress in Louisiana and
she's going to get elected.
You imagine she,
she's pro industry.
Do you know,
not understand what that means.
That's what gives people jobs.
Full charge keeps America strong.
Right?
America is a bunch.
I mean there's a bunch of great things
about America.
America is pretty awesome.
No burgers,
but there's a bunch of dumb shit in
America that likes to call itself
America,
right?
You know,
american values,
american standards,
the free and it's people that have that
sort of this kind of mentality,
this sorta just low voltage sludgy
sludgy.
Sloppy thinking.
Yeah.
She's hot enough that she'll probably
get in just based on looks.
Pro chicks are highs.
Fucking Louisiana dude.
Oh that's great.
Women are hot as fuck down there.
The chief got no chance with the.
If a hot one runs against her.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's all she has to do is show up at
like farmer's markets.
Talk to people.
She's in.
So on hotness alone.
So what about what she's saying though,
where she's like,
it's,
it is colder this year and there are.
There is more ice in antarctica.
True.
Okay.
Tell him no.
It's like everyone is global warming
real.
Everybody's sure.
Everybody believes it's real.
Yeah.
Everyone kind of brings their own facts.
The only arguments that I've heard at
all that make any sense whatsoever is
that human addition to global warming is
just one factor and that there's a cycle
that happens all the time,
but humans are accelerating that cycle.
I've heard that argument.
That makes a lot of sense.
That means that makes more sense to me
than humans have no effect on it and it
makes more sense to me than humans are
the cause of it entirely.
I have a feeling that if you look at all
those,
you know those when those guys do those
core samples and they find out the
temperature of a thousand years ago when
they start examining the earth and the
crust for all these different layers and
some of them they can,
they could tell temperatures and
asteroidal impacts and all this
different things.
It's pretty obvious that a bunch of
stuff's been happening.
We've ice ages come and go.
We've had hot spells when the dinosaurs
were alive.
Apparently it was like a completely
different atmosphere,
much thicker atmosphere.
I read this thing about they were trying
to speculate as to why the dinosaurs
were so large and one of the things was
that it might have been because the
atmosphere was different.
It was a thicker,
more rich atmosphere that just naturally
facilitated larger animals,
larger creatures,
especially lizards.
Global warming isn't real.
The global warming controversy is global
warming real.
What we know about global warming,
the skeptic society says it's real how
we know global warming is real.
Human induced climate change.
Atmospheric carbon dioxide
concentrations are higher today than at
any other time in the last 650,000
years.
They were about 35 percent higher than
before the industrial revolution.
And this increase is caused by human
activities.
Primarily the burning of fossil fuels.
Carbon dioxide is a greenhouse gas as
our methane nitrous.
I'm gonna sneeze.
What are,
excuse me,
water vapor and a host of other
horseshit.
So yeah,
it's global warming.
It's real.
Okay,
that makes sense.
I'm going with them instead of a.
That chick,
was it hard to accept that,
that things are gonna change?
Well,
you know,
full charge at my church,
we have these discussions about the lame
stream media and trying to figure out
why the lame stream media media
continues to lotto America.
That's when she said lanes,
media.
You have to like at that point you've
got to go.
We can't just keep talking.
We can keep talking.
You think that's acceptable?
And she said like,
she was like shutting them down.
I'm putting them on blast to lame stream
media debt.
Imagine getting that lady high on
mushrooms.
Imagine taking her to the forest.
I'll just a bunch of guys,
not just guys.
That sounds like a bunch of people and
everybody drag her along.
Yeah.
And then just listen.
We're just gonna get you gonna you gonna
eat these mushrooms with us and then
we'll do whatever you want.
Okay,
so we'll vote for you.
Will do whatever you want.
You just got to do this first we'll
listen to you get real big fucking jar
of them with apple sauce mixed in.
Look at it.
The joe rogan kinda hot in a weird
milfy.
Well I can look at is people's necks.
That's not even a real bro.
You photoshop that.
You did brian.
Brian,
you hit the volume.
Jesus christ.
You fucking.
It's like a big volume.
I'm jeff.
The headphone didn't affect the
recording now just to add funds.
Use photoshop that you fuck.
No,
I didn't think we're stupid.
That's a vagina.
So luckily she swallowed a bow and arrow
that's
going on in her neck.
Was a guy named merrill.
Heck no,
it's not.
That's christy.
Is it real?
It is.
No,
it is a real doctor that up.
Yeah,
of course it.
Did you fuck.
He thinks it's funny.
So I'm mature,
man.
He put a vagina on a woman's neck and a
woman is running for congress.
First of all,
it's unpatriotic.
Regardless whether or not you agree with
her,
you will respect her.
It's unamerican,
brian.
People.
There are people that believe that,
that you're supposed to respect that
person,
right?
You're not supposed to mock her.
Right.
First of all,
she's a lady.
Second of all,
she's congress representative.
She's going to.
She's going to become the president one
day.
Imagine if that's where we went and we
went full fucking full apocalypto.
I couldn't handle that climate deniers.
Just fuck it up so bad that the ocean
start to boil.
Call a fish,
kid cooked.
We all have to move to the center of
the.
We all have to live in South Dakota.
It turns out people can all live in
south.
Yeah,
everyone,
everyone.
Everyone's.
That's all that's left.
Everything else is just hot water.
We got to.
You got to go where it's really fucking
cold.
So Canada becomes the number one spot.
All of a sudden there's only 20 million
people in all of Canada.
That's wild,
huh?
Yeah.
That's how I.
That's crazy.
I'm pretty sure that's right.
Let's see.
How many people are in Canada?
I'm pretty sure I read that.
How many people live in Canada?
Too much time in Canada.
What's great in the montreal?
That's fantastic.
And I've been to winnipeg.
Winnipeg is 34,
34 point 8 million people,
so yeah.
What is that?
That's like la and 20 million las,
like $20 million.
I bet it's like the west coast,
a best of the whole west coast.
Have you took the whole west coast from?
Certainly from Mexico,
but I mean from like san diego all the
way up to Washington state.
Yeah,
I bet you would get 40 and so that's all
Canada,
the whole,
the whole thing,
right.
The whole giant north America.
That's while it's cold.
I mean it's cold.
What can,
what can I tell you?
None of global warming.
That would really work.
Well,
we need to do you mean I have a friend
who lives in northern alberta?
Yeah.
And he just bought or he's looking at
this land.
There's 160 acres for $70,000.
Wow.
Yet greenland might be like the new go
to Hawaii place in the future or
whatever that or Iceland or.
Yup.
If it's still not,
it was not under the ocean.
That's the problem.
You've got to really hedge your bets
when you're going to do this whole,
uh,
when you're looking towards the future,
you know,
like you sit in the guy's office,
there's a whole thing about global
warming.
It's an opportunity.
There's always an opportunity to
probably know there's someone out there
loves prognostication.
I mean it's.
It's a tricky business.
You've got to really speculate.
We a lot of people are going to drown
and there's a lot of bleeding hearts
problem with that.
There was.
The people are going to
drown anyway.
Okay.
What I'm looking at is what's going to
be above ground and what we've come up
with is nova scotia is much higher
altitude.
I got two words for you.
North pole.
I'm listening to like a house
overlooking the ocean that isn't
there yet.
Okay,
well all we need to do,
my friend is getting permits.
Not only can I give you a permit,
but I can name a star after you sign
here on this little star registries and
they named a star after naming us star
ftp.
You shut the fuck up program star named
dr.
Yeah,
fucking saint nicholas
men should be st nick.
Saint nicholas,
the star for the price of a cup of
coffee.
I bought my own store.
Twenty $5,
$25 in the future.
We have the technology to go to all
these planets that they,
that they named and stuff,
and you actually get to own it based off
like a $29 purchase.
Planets.
Planets are rare and difficult to find
stars.
There was enough stars that I think they
had the mean really fucking brilliant.
If you think how stupid people have to
be that you use
pay someone to write on a piece of paper
that the star's name,
it's not your fucking star man,
and by the way,
that started to give a shit what you
name it,
got permission from another person who
doesn't have that permission named
fucking star to you start an explosion.
You just got your name,
dr.
You named a explosion.
Not only that,
it might not even be not even still some
of those lights that you see in the sky
or from a million years ago.
Millions of years ago,
millions of light years away.
So the light that's reaching right now,
it might've already.
We've burnt
out.
Sure.
My leg,
you might have blown out right when they
first figured out about those hyper
novas sometime during.
I think it was like the early two
thousands.
They first want to say no,
no,
no.
That was when they first figured out
that inside every galaxy was a black
hole,
but they,
they came up with this new detection
equipment and uh,
I forgot what year it was.
I should probably look it up while we're
talking about it.
But when did they invent hyper novas?
But they found out event discover
hybridomas because he didn't vet them
hyper.
This is where I get really dumb.
There's black holes and every galaxy you
said they believe that there are in
every galaxy.
This,
and this is a fairly recent.
Over the last decade they believed that
it at the center of every galaxy is a
supermassive black hole that is one half
of one percent of the mass of the entire
galaxy.
So the bigger the galaxy,
the bigger the black hole and that
inside each black hole,
maybe another universe.
Okay,
that's fine.
That checks out.
There's a bit of a mind fuck yeah,
a bit of a mind.
Fuck.
Do you ever see that movie?
The black hole?
It was like a fake star wars.
Yeah.
Disney.
I don't remember that.
What was that like an imitation star
wars movie.
Oh no,
it wasn't.
Yeah,
it was a raincoat robots in it.
Somewhat popular,
but obviously it wasn't as good as star
wars.
You remember buck rogers?
Yeah,
that was the bottom.
Okay.
This is.
It was in 1990,
the 19 nineties that they figured it out
in 1998 paper suggesting a link between
gamma ray bursts and young,
massive stars.
Formerly propo proposed the term hyper
nova.
They had some sort of a measuring
equipment and they were.
They were detecting so many explosions
in the sky that they thought that there
was a war amongst aliens thrill.
It's just something that was actively
being considered because all throughout
the day,
apparently like all day long,
if you have the proper measuring
equipment,
you can detect hyper novas that are
taking place way out in the far reaches
of the galaxy and what they are is
they're stars that are blowing up,
so it's.
It's happening like all over the
universe,
but these bursts are so strong.
If they're anywhere near us,
we'd be dead.
Right.
Like if they were at a nearby star or
nearby solar system and it went hyper
nova.
That's a wrap.
That's a wrap for this whole galaxy.
All lives most likely dead,
right?
Yeah.
That's a good way to go.
A nearby hyper nova.
Let's.
Let's,
let's google what it would say nearby
was dangerous of a nearby hyper over
death.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean there's so many stars out there
that I don't know if it would be.
It would be possible,
but if it.
I mean it certainly would be possible.
I don't know how likely it would be,
but.
But the numbers of stars are just.
It's insane.
Hundreds of billions just in our galaxy.
Just.
I don't think he can even understand.
I think it's just numbers,
right?
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
I can't really.
Destruction of earth by a nearby
supernova.
This is on the nasa page.
Be careful job.
You destroy the earth itself.
The sun will have to go supernova,
which it never will.
If you're talking about life on earth,
then there is a detailed calculation of
the risks due to a nearby supernova on
the web.
Oh,
there's a.
There's actually a thing that calculates
the risks.
The author concludes that a supernova
has to be within 10 parsecs or 30 light
years to be dangerous to life on earth.
That is because the atmosphere shields
us from most dangerous radiation
radiation astronauts into orbit may be
in danger if supernova is within a
thousand parsecs or soul.
So if they were up in space,
it would be a thousand parsecs,
so 100 times more.
So $300,
million light years,
or three light years rather.
Wow.
Crazy man.
No star currently within 20 parsecs will
go supernova within the next few million
years.
That's a relief.
I feel so much better.
That's my biggest fear.
That would be a motherfucker dude.
One day.
It all goes bright.
I listened to the lame stream media all
day.
The lame stream media,
constantly paranoid of things.
They could call it a high pernova.
All.
What I know is it's angels coming was
just latin berg.
When the angels come,
the satellites go down,
that god has a great sense of evil.
The lame stream media would want to
believe that the supernovas are to be
feared,
but god's plan includes all of us.
God's plan.
Amen.
When is that going to go away?
I don't think it will.
What is that accent going to go away?
Uh,
I think people love it.
I think they,
they,
they love it and they're going to keep
it going as long as they can.
I think they should keep it going just
for the chicks.
Yeah,
right.
For the chicks alone,
it's the best.
It's the best.
Doesn't get any better.
But for dudes,
a little hickey.
I think if you're a country music fan,
it could work if the guys gentlemen
could work.
But if the gods explaining thermo
nuclear power,
right,
were like,
what?
It's fucking hickey cock sucker.
Let's throw some harvard on there that
we're working with fusion and the wife
fusion works is we have the nuclear
where you feel feel the water into the
broads and it's create steam.
And then this thing,
oh,
you shut this fucking guy up and get a
real scientist in near get someone from
harvard,
someone with a good,
good,
strong new england accent.
Exactly.
Listening to soccer.
But you listen to people from harvard
scientists from harvard.
No boston accent whatsoever.
Yeah.
The transplants,
right?
No,
they're smart enough to know that
accident sucks and it's going to devalue
all their arguments points.
Yeah.
The only time that accent doesn't suck
because if you're drinking,
that's okay.
Yeah.
That is great.
I mean,
I love to listen to it.
Yeah.
If you're drinking and you're hearing
stories,
but if it's a judge he's about to
sentence you and he's got a boston
accent,
like it's going to be a big one mat
full.
Please approach the bench when you have
qa feed off of that road because you had
been drinking.
You violated the laws of weymouth,
Massachusetts.
Oh,
do you ever have that bill?
Every bill bird tell that story about
how he in a court and I'm there reading
his testimony and the cop asked him
where is he going?
And he said,
fucking boston.
And he goes,
bill explained to like,
nah,
you know,
I'm from boston.
It's like a.
When you asked me,
I was just thinking when I was saying if
I like,
ah,
fuck in boston,
I wasn't cursing like you think I was.
Yeah.
Like,
like it's like indignant statement.
Oh,
in trying to be rude as fuck.
Fucking boston.
They read that off a piece of paper at
his court case.
That's so funny.
That's the problem with the word fuck
that.
It's kind of the word us sometimes.
Yeah.
You fucking fucking fucking fuck.
Fuck this guy.
This fucking guy.
You saw that on paper.
You'd be like,
this is a really angry person.
Right.
You know,
but it's just a guy with a bad
vocabulary.
That's why twitter doesn't work,
man.
Context context.
Absolutely.
Do you don't get context when you just
read it?
No.
Even if you know the person you're
reading from,
it doesn't always work.
Sometimes it works.
If you know the person you're reading
from like rise and shine cock suckers.
When it comes to the show ideas.
Sure.
You know,
at 6:00
AM and it's time to get up.
Yeah.
You know exactly what that is.
Joey diaz did this thing recently where
he was talking about being proud to be
an american.
It did like this,
this ramp,
and then they put the national anthem
over it,
pull it up,
pull it up.
He did a rant with the national anthem.
He's like,
can you get me going?
Put the fucking national anthem bond he.
Have you ever been up like crazy early
in the morning and listen to it?
Yeah.
Well yeah.
And he's also up on twitter at like 5:00
AM.
He gets a break giving people music to
listen to.
So he's done that.
He's always gotten up really early and
he's always gone to bed really early to
try to call him joey at midnight.
Really?
Joe?
He's dead.
He's asleep.
He's out cold.
So what time does he normally go to bed?
Does it show?
Leaves a shame on me.
He'll like if we do a 10:00
show who gets to bed at 1:00
in the morning to write,
but he doesn't like to do that.
He likes to be in bed by like 11.
Huh?
I'm in bed by 11.
I'm in no danger.
Yeah,
he likes to.
He but he's american.
Okay,
so the fucking mexicans are taking your
job.
The russians.
Armenians caught it.
The fuck out.
Go down in this country is 240 fucking
years old.
Correct?
Seventeen 76.
They became a country because we're bet
play the fucking national anthem because
they got me fired up
140 fucking years we've been around.
We have a greatest fucking everybody.
But guess what?
Don't mistake kindness for weakness.
Fucking american.
And you've to get up of that little
circle of friends who app that tell you
don't go down there and not going to
hire you.
They're not gonna.
Hire you fucking loser.
You're going to grab your fucking balls.
You're going to take this shit.
You gonna wipe your ass.
You're going to brush your teeth.
You're going to put gel in your head.
You gonna fucking whatever the fuck put
mount Washington,
your fucking mouth and you're gonna.
Go down and you going to go,
listen,
I know you're not hiring,
but I'm the best mother fucked
available.
Do you know why?
Because I'm a fucking american.
Okay,
fuck I am.
I'm a fucking american mother.
Fuckers.
Fucking habits.
Tommy closed.
When you fucking get it pops up.
You're a fucking american.
Stop.
Fucking whining.
I'm sick of you motherfuckers who onto
him.
Forty years we've been slinging and
you're still wondering about
the unemployment rate.
One unemployment rate.
It's only in your head.
You need deep.
I'm sorry.
After a weekend with a bunch of fucking
gentiles get up.
It's monday.
It's a beautiful fucking dead to be a
lot.
I hope you don't live in an apartment.
If,
if he does,
he doesn't care.
I know.
I like how he just basically did with
like the jerky boys did.
He told you to do with the jerky boys do
like I'm the fucking best run circles
around you mother fuckers.
You got down there.
That works for me.
That's exactly what the jerky boys
missed their time.
They did a movie and everything,
but the jerky boys that they had been on
the internet.
Yeah.
If the jerky boys came out today,
some of those fucking things would have
millions of hits.
Yeah,
they.
But we had to pass those tapes around a
morale.
Yeah,
that was one of my favorite things that
ever happened was the jerky boys from a
friend,
a friend would get it and somehow knew
they would make a copy for you and
they'd get you the jerky boys.
That's how became famous.
I bought it from a friend.
He goes,
I feel bad selling you this because
after you listen to it twice,
you never going to listen to it again.
I've been quoting this shit everyday for
20,
25 years.
I fucking love the jerky boys.
Are we recording?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Do.
They had some funny shit.
Oh my god.
The one guy,
one guy was really good.
The one guy was really good.
One that was okay with the other guy was
really phenomenal.
I don't know which guy was which,
but a really fucking funny stuff.
If you go back and listen to it today.
Laughs.
Yeah.
That was one of those things.
It was like,
what if you did pranks back then?
It was hard to get appreciated.
It was hard to,
you know,
to do something along those lines.
And then remember when jimmy,
jimmy kimmel had a tv show.
Cranky anchors.
Yeah.
And he had puppets.
Puppets would.
Comics would do the prank phone calls
and they would call it in.
Puppets would reenact it.
That's great.
That was hilarious.
I totally forgot about the florentines
thing.
Was the best.
Was jim florentine
the guy that goes,
yay,
I'm going to come to your store lady.
Where is it?
The answer was yes.
And he called everyone lady.
Whether you're a man or a woman,
how much to see air bud lady?
$5.
Yay.
That's brilliant.
That is.
That's hilarious.
And there's one more.
Mitch hedberg called up and wanted to
join a guy's band.
That one's fucking phenomenal.
He called up and wanted to.
It was like,
you saw a want ad that was like,
we're looking for a guitar player.
And he called them say,
oh,
but I'm kind of a singer too,
man.
You know,
check out these goals to go right to
that one.
Yankers mitch hedberg band.
I think it's hard to find.
You'll find it.
He'll find it.
He knows he's not like youthful jacia.
No,
I give up after three seconds.
He's got magic fingers in a good sense
of google.
Yeah.
I haven't even called a t and t to tell
my internet's down.
Mitch hedberg cranking.
I like how he's playing the character
to.
Yeah,
you got to see this.
No.
Hey,
is jerry there?
Yeah.
Okay,
hold on for a second.
No,
is he there?
Is that you would just turn down your
music.
That's why he put me on a whole.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's cool.
I thought I thought like you got a
secretary,
so.
Oh really?
How about now?
No,
now I can hear you fine.
Oh,
well I'm talking to the same level of
man your.
Is that I'm a musician man.
I'm calling you up.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
You're lookIng for some jam partners,
rIght?
Uh,
yeah,
actually what we're looking for is a
singer.
Well yeah man,
I sing and I play guitar man.
But you know what I'm saying is no
problem.
And you know,
people put a mic up to my mouth.
I belt it out.
Yeah.
Well we're looking for a real lead
singer.
Well,
if you,
if you want me to say I have like a
real,
you know,
I like to like,
yeah,
lIke,
you know,
what do you like?
That kind of thing.
I hate melody.
You know,
I,
I'm purely against melly.
Where,
where are you calling from?
I'm hannah.
I'm from my phone.
Yeah.
No,
I mean you live in nassau.
Suffolk.
I'm part of that.
I'm part of the suffolk death metal
contingent.
The heavier stuff.
Oh yeah.
The heavier,
the better man.
well,
if you want,
I'll take your name and number and if
the other guys are interested we'll call
you back.
All right man.
But I know people,
I know people at mtv two,
you know,
so you should probably hook up with me.
What's your,
uh,
what's your name?
My name is mitch.
Mitch and I got long hair.
Okay.
Yeah man,
it's way past my nipples.
Well,
I don't have a phone right now.
You know,
I spent my,
I spent all my money on the distortion
pedals and stuff.
You have to write a song about a
unicorn.
No,
I wrote this kick ass.
I'm about a unicorn.
It's a unicorn.
Who has a story though?
Did I unicorn?
Goes through the ups and downs and then
in the end
you didn't call you.
I'm just going to be rehearsing now so
you know what?
Let's jam right now over the phone.
No,
I got it.
I got to go.
Okay.
Let's just play a tune right now.
Mean to you.
I got
it.
I got people in my house right now.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So call me in a week or so.
All right.
Take it easy.
His
voice is just music to my ears,
man.
Yeah.
Well especially now.
So after he's gone,
he did other ones.
He's doing bong hits on the cat.
Oh,
that's the end of it.
And what was the other one?
That jim florentine florentine.
His name is special ed,
I think.
Is that still legal?
Can you still do that?
Can you call people up?
It used to be that you could do it as
long as you did it in vegas.
Debts.
That's their loophole.
I don't know what the deal is now.
This show probably ruined it.
You know the show what crank crank
wreck.
Yeah.
Great.
So I wOnder with it,
can I go?
Yes.
Um,
I'm trying to track a package that was
supposed to be delivered to my sister
when was this boat to get to her
address?
But they didn't make their first
attempt.
I think the character's name is special
eD,
but that seems weird,
like she's calling them to try to get a
package tracked and they're fucking
around.
There's a couple of guys,
jim florentine and don jamison do this
thing called the touchstone terrorists
and they have a number thAt a lot of
people call as the customer service
number and,
and they also do telemarketers.
So the people that call,
they think it's an actual customer
service number.
Yeah.
I might be getting,
I might be getting some of that
information.
We would have so many hands because it
seemed like that's what she was dOing.
It seemed like she was calling like she
had a real problem.
Right.
I've heard this one before and it's even
worse than calling somebody,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
It's kinDa fucked up.
That's even worse.
Like if they're calling you,
they've got a real issue that needed to
fix.
No.
Yeah,
you know a florentine does is he,
he just tapes every conversation and
when telemarketers call him he,
he fucks with them so bad.
That's smart.
Yeah.
Well that should be totally legal.
Yeah,
that should be.
that should be the one tIme where you,
you could get away with stuff like that.
Just fuck with telemarketer.
Yeah.
That's a miserable job though,
man,
to make that job more miserable.
The people.
I can't imagine.
Hi belinda ad.
So you got air bud.
The video?
Yeah,
I've got airbags.
Hey,
I love era bud.
Yay.
I want to come down there and get it.
Okay.
Um,
do you have the shining?
We do.
Scared.
Can you,
can you take it out on his door before I
got there?
I can
all work and no blame.
Makes a dull boy.
oh.
Oh.
Steps,
steps,
biceps,
biceps.
Okay.
Yay.
I've got some other customers.
See or that I really need the help
and is in here.
Mr.
Oh okay.
Is it here?
Mr.
Know what this is.
This is someone,
you know,
someone took the soundbites and did
their own prank phone calls.
That's why it's not that,
you know.
Yeah.
That's why I was repeating all this
stuff.
oh wow.
You sure?
I'm pretty sure.
Sure.
It wasn't just psychotic.
What seemed like it was just psychotic.
Yeah.
I think that was somebody else doing
this using like a soundboard.
I don't know.
That would be a good call if you just
did it like that because it was so
crazy.
Yeah.
That was a big thing for awhile.
Pranking.
Yeah.
You know,
not so much anymore.
No,
I used to do it without recording it.
Which is fucking sounds kinda dumb.
Did you ever see the one where the dude
was walking up to people and he,
uh,
he's asking them if they want to kiss
his ass.
He's like a donkey in his pocket.
Just saw that.
Do you want to kiss my ass?
And this one guy sucker punches him and
knocks him out.
Cold knocks his teeth through his lips.
Yeah.
The guy just,
he just loses all control of his body in
one second while he just got knocked the
fuck out.
And I mean it was bad.
His lip like was torn.
His cheek was torn open.
You could see through his cheek to his
teeth.
He got punched through his,
uh,
his lower lip.
Yeah.
The point where his teeth went through
his,
uh,
his face.
Yeah.
He,
he asked the wrong guy the wrong
question.
Well,
the guy told him to back the fuck off
and he was still like,
do you want to kiss my ass?
Like he thought he was being cute
because he was getting filmed and then
he was getting like people were calling
fake because he wasn't mad.
Like when he was getting interviewed
after,
you know,
they had a camera on him,
like he was on his way to the hospital.
He was all fucked up.
I'm like,
no,
that's bullshit.
He would be pissed off.
That guy punched him.
Like,
now he's an idiot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This things.
It's cute.
Not smart to begin with.
He thinks it's funny that he got knocked
out.
Do you ever see the one with the kid
jumps out of a trashcan and the guy
punches him?
Yep.
That's.
Whoa.
That's a classic animated gifts,
right?
So that's a classic one.
That's so great.
Someone needs to have that as their
avatar.
My message board.
That's so funny.
They would pop up,
boom,
the gun with him,
when he'd go right back into it,
you should have video that somebody
released that were like a.
It was like a mma fight or a small,
like a some kind of fight and then the
judge starts beating up the two guys
because he's tried to break them up and
they wouldn't break up and then the
judge just the referee starts just
beating them up.
I'll find it for you.
I don't want to see it.
That's okay.
Yeah,
I'm sure it happens.
It's so great that we have so much
footage of so much nonsense.
I saw bad worldstar one the other day
where some guy knocked this guy out onto
the hood of a car.
He just steps
up to this guy,
like the guy sitting there and he steps.
He's like sitting next to a car and he
steps up and smashes them in the face,
knocking them out,
cold the goggles flying back into the
grill of the car and then crumbles and
the other guy's yelling,
worldstar.
I was like,
really?
Like the humanity.
There's a certain segment of the human
race that doesn't give a fuck about the
rest of the human race.
That's true.
They really don't give a fuck.
It's kind of scary and you could find
that segment represented well on
worldstar hip hop.com.
Absolutely.
They don't mind punching each other in
the face or punching you in the face.
Yeah,
it's fine.
It's just part of life.
Did you see the one the other day?
I think bill burt tweeted.
It is a kid.
He's riding his bicycle.
He pushes bicycle punches.
His kid in the face,
jumps off the bike,
runs by,
punches his kid in the face.
Then jumps on the bike.
Yeah.
He goes,
jesus,
who's ghost riding his bike?
Sucker punched this kid in the face and
then jumped back on the bike and
runaway.
These little kids tried to sucker punch
me one time in baltimore.
I was lifeguard and this pool really?
And they,
they came up,
they wanted to go swimming,
so they just walked up.
They were like eight years old and they
go,
hey,
come here.
I want to tell you something.
Dude goes to punch me.
I move out of the way.
They all jumped in the pool,
jump out and run away.
Whoa.
And that's actually the story.
Jump out and run away.
Yeah.
They just want to jump in the pool for a
second.
Did they show the kid picking on the kid
first?
Yeah.
At first there was here.
You could say the whole thing.
We don't see it,
brian,
so he rides off.
They got upset.
The smaller guy rides off on his bike.
He's also the one that used the n word
and he turns around,
starts back down the road.
It seems like he planned this out.
I think it's playing.
It goes rides the bike.
He chases his bike and then jumps back.
Either way.
That's the eight year old worldstar.
Yeah,
that's what that is.
That's where world start.
When he can knock people out,
yet he punched people.
They don't get desperately hurt like
they do in the other video.
They just get mildly annoyed.
Yeah.
Part of it's more fucked up because you
know they're eight,
but part of it's way better because they
can't do as much damage.
Right,
right.
Part of you knows they'll be doing that
at 80.
Of course.
Of course,
if they could stick in that
neighborhood,
they could stick it out.
They'll be doing something way worse.
That guy will be in a way better video
10 years from now with a better bike
too.
It's going to be like solar power,
you think?
So?
I did.
I saw a bike in a bike shop the other
day.
Whether it was a vintage bike.
Do you know the people were in the
vintage bikes?
Sure.
Is an old piece of shit bike and it was
$5,000,
I believe it was this it just a regular
bike shop.
I went into get something for my kids,
getting little kid bikes and they had a
vintage bike and it was an ugly piece of
shit and then like rust was coming
through the chrome,
the seat was kind of fucked up and the
guy was like,
it's all original parts.
I was like,
what?
Like how much is this?
The guy was like $5,000.
It's a classic of this is a class,
this is where something can.
Can I ride this car?
Like they're trying to do that same shit
that they do with like old cars.
Like if you buy at 55 chevrolet,
you go,
whoa,
original dash.
This is amazing.
But a bike,
a bike from that era,
oh my god,
that's worthless.
There's a whole bike culture that we're
just not these guys,
they're just all about their bikes.
Brooklyn is insane.
Really?
Brooklyn,
New York,
everyone's got a bike real.
It's insanity.
Did they steal bikes?
No.
There's like these expensive bike shops
and there's all these bike paths and
especially in williamsburg,
brooklyn,
it's a fucking scene and all these guys
are into it.
Real hipster thing.
It's a hipster thing.
The hips are well,
that's a good thing for hipsters to be
involved with.
At least it's going to get them outside,
get the hipsters exercised.
I'm looking at bikes right now because
my just,
I leave my bike outside and the weather
is just destroyed my looking at bikes to
the actual ride or to just sit there and
take notes and write.
I like riding bikes,
especially on burbank because there's a
lot of weird pass,
you know,
go to the cemetery or Michael Jackson is
all around there.
That'd be great for you dude.
Ride bikes.
It's healthy.
Yeah.
I knew a dude who,
uh,
he rode a bike to jujitsu every night.
Then he wrote home would do who would
ride the bike,
train and then ride home and I was like,
that's got to be a lot of work.
He's like,
yup.
But it gets you in incredible shape.
Right?
You get used to pumping.
But I also think it's like the worst
time to be breathing heavy when you're
around break fumes and hurt is not that
good.
Dust and hurts actually kind of bad for
you to do cardio next to the traffic.
Yeah.
And it's not like you could take that
bike through the fucking woods.
He can't,
not really mountain bike.
It's terrifying.
Riding a bike around la.
That is people are texting and shit.
Hadn't burbank burbank's.
Not even in like,
oh nobody texts in burbank and not even
people,
but there's like no traffic in my
neighborhood.
The tonight show,
there's something about the way jay leno
ran that room,
right?
That all that areas like super safe to
drive.
Did you hear that?
What that book that's coming out all
about jay leno's like past guests,
like all these,
like weird things that happen.
Like how like when a Jessica Simpson was
on,
she demanded a $15,000
haircut before she,
she got on and like all these weird
things that people demanded.
I would bet there's a lot of that prima
shit that went on.
I heard Jessica Simpson did like 30
takes on the tonight show on time.
30 teachers song going,
kept going and they planned on editing
the shit out of it was a song.
Uh,
you remember when her and her husband
jay brow producer reveals a list guests
most outrageous
demands.
Oh,
jesus.
He's the guy who did it.
Michael moore.
Yeah,
he was the producer.
Michael moore threatened not to go on
just before the show taped,
unless the producers at greed to areas,
homemade video.
He had us over a barrel and myths that
he caved in but didn't invite more back
like,
huh?
Wonder what that was about?
Yeah.
quentin tarantino was drunk as fuck.
they,
they sent bill clinton a $12,000
custom bike,
uh,
after it was 2004 heart surgery.
Clinton kept the bike but never made his
appearance.
How old was hilarious?
A sarah pailin as for a private jet to
fly here from Alaska to burbank for
2010.
Apparently it costs $35,000
and they gave it to her.
Oh my god.
Well that was probably a scoop back then
to get her 2010 when they first
announced she's running for president.
So 2010 was when they first announced it
for the 2012 elections.
That means that right now we're about on
target,
right?
It's 2014.
So this year is when we're going to
start seeing the real election rumblings
into next year.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who's going to run for president?
I don't know.
We had a bushes were of that job.
Got a job.
Yeah.
We've got a gentleman and he's been
quiet.
He secretly sneak in silently.
Stealthily sneak in.
Right?
Probably.
I'm voting for roseanna.
Roseanne barr.
I think she did last time.
She believes in chem trails,
but I love her.
Oh,
she.
I don't know if she doesn't even listen
to that episode.
I explained it to her.
I hope she listened.
Yeah.
She totally believed in it.
So to crash.
Crash on the float lab yesterday.
Yeah.
He's big on chem trails to cam shows.
I've seen him in a sky as they always
say.
I see them.
It's because of their excellent point.
Who is?
Who else is running?
They got that a ted cruz guy,
right?
he's a republican.
That gets talked about a lot.
There's hillary clinton who just fucked
up because she tried to say that they
were dead brOke.
she was trying to pick a ploy to a
poverty saying that when the bill got
out of the office,
they were dead broke.
She never said that.
First of all because they made a lot of
money during the presidency and on top
of that they also had tremendous money
coming in right afterwards.
He's made over $100,000,000
just in speaking.
Right.
Just speaking from then until now and
then writing books and all that other
jazz,
like for her to saY we were ted probably
for her to bitch and this fucked up
wacky economy where people can't get
jobs.
LIke everybody knows you're rich.
What are you crazy?
You're really talking about the time we
were.
Oh,
we were dead broke and bill got out of
the office for a whole hour until the
first check came in until he did his
first one hour speech for $189,000
for 40 minutes to talk and we're doing
fine.
After that.
it seemed to be okay and everything was
going to be all right.
First year he made about $80,000,000,
wrote a book.
They got money fucking coming out of
their asshole.
Like,
what are you talking about it.
Oh,
when you're a guy like bill clinton,
people will always pay to hear you talk.
Yeah.
That's what they do.
That's the lecture circuit.
They'll show up at universities.
Universities have fuck loads of money
when it comes to things like that at
all.
They use,
you know,
they have think about how many people go
to a major university and paid $20,000
or whatever it is for tuition.
That's a sIzeable chunk they give to a
president.
Absolutely.
Um,
I mean,
I know if you could make a lot doing
comedy,
I know you can make a real lot doing
fucking if you're a former president.
My wife went to see giuliani speak once.
When he came to ucla.
it was like post September 11th.
Like,
what am I spend way post?
Because it wasn't that long ago.
Whatever it was,
it was a.
She said it was like the most boring
fucking thing she'd ever seen her life.
She couldn't believe that anybody would
pay to see it.
It was like there was no passion to it.
It was numb.
It was just saying nothing.
And he just spoke for an hour about.
Was there any topic.
I think they always have topics,
you know,
maybe he had a book out oR something
like that.
You know,
they,
they go on a lecture tour and they just,
they just spit it out.
Like with no Bull.
He mentioned public speaking without the
pressure of meeting get laughs.
Well then the problem is public speaking
without laughs,
it's usually pretty shitty.
Yeah.
Even like a lot of these guys that do
lectures,
they tell fucking jokes.
They know.
Yeah.
Like you ever listen to ted talks a no.
Those ted,
those,
you know,
those things online,
those science talks where they discussed
the university even ever.
I don't think I've ever seen one.
No,
but they have jokes in them.
Right,
and missing out.
Yeah.
People always have humor.
Always break things.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're missing out,
bro.
You don't know about the ted.
I'll get on it.
It's kind of called it.
I'm off tour,
dude.
I'll get on.
I got free time.
They're very culty apparently.
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
How so?
Well,
they want everybody who's speaking to
sleep together in the same room.
Yeah,
like you would have to share a room like
say if you and I were speaking right,
you'd have to share a hotel room
together because they wanted people to
get to know each other,
wanting to forcibly like people with
money.
Like eddie wong,
who's a famous chef from New York,
was speaking at a ted conference.
They wouldn't let him get his own hotel
room.
They made him stay and they got mad at
him when he came here to do our podcasts
instead of stay and,
and meet with all these other people
because they have this 10 thing and when
they have the ted thing,
they meet like you have a bunch of ted
fellows.
People paid for ted memberships and they
come to these things.
They want you to go to events and be
there to talk with them and meet with
them.
Huh?
It gets like super weird,
super controlling and kind of,
and not just from one person.
We've heard that from a bunch of people.
Sarah silverman,
they pulled her on there because she's
good because she was doing what she
does.
Being a fucking comedian.
She was telling jokes and being funny
and they're like disrespectful.
They censored graham hancock.
They pulled his thing down to,
they invited him to go on and he came on
and he told this,
uh,
this,
interesting story about psychedelics and
the,
uh,
they got upset and sensitive and because
they censored it got way more attention,
right?
It became hugely popular online.
It's hundreds of thousands of hits after
that and re replayed on a bunch of
different youtube sites too because
people were scared they were gonna try
to pull it down.
Right?
So it's really good.
Really good videos that are kinda shady.
Some of them are great.
The way they run it.
It's the,
the,
the business is kind of shady
businesses.
I mean,
look,
shady is first of all,
pulling things like there,
they're pulling it down for the graham
hancock one.
Like he made a very,
very detailed argument against pulling
it down and he wanted.
He demanded to know like,
what about what I'm saying is
pseudoscientific,
please explain if you're,
if you're so concerned that you pulled
down.
Like these are real things like talking
about iowasca.
These are real beneficial things that
people can experience.
The science behind the experience is
real.
The history behind the experiences.
Real document against it.
It's very interesting.
Yeah.
It's an ancient and it's his theory.
These are his theories about knowledge
being gained from taking these
psychedelics,
but they pulled him down.
But that the eddie wong thing is more
disturbing to me that they told him that
they will not more disturbing but almost
more disturbing because they made him
sleep with another person in a room
together.
I think that's,
I don't like that.
I cool fucker you that I don't care for
adults here,
you know,
get my own room if.
Especially the one thing,
if you didn't have the budget but if you
wanted to pay,
but you're like,
no,
I want you to team up with this guy.
He's a,
you know,
nuclear waste detector guy from
yugoslavia who's giving a speech.
I know this guy fart and fucking snoring
next to me.
This is stupid.
No privacy.
That's like a physical thing when you go
up and have to make a speech.
You want a little bit of relaxation,
a little bit of privacy beforehand.
Yeah.
Before we leave graham hancock,
put this on his,
uh,
his twitter today and I retweeted it.
Magic potion discovered with potential
to end all wars.
It's a,
it's only a minute and a half,
but it's a youtube clip about when they
dosed soldiers up in the 19 fifties with
lsd.
And you've ever seen that video?
None.
Ever seen the video,
but I've heard about this.
It's classic pull.
Pull it up brian,
and we'll wrap this bitch up and we'll
go home with this because it's kind of
hilarious.
It's hilarious that uh,
I don't know what year this was.
They did this,
I hope,
a drink of water.
Given that the housewife.
No.
Twenty five soldiers later,
the first effect of the drug became a
pattern.
The men began to relax them to giggle.
But this man was more seriously affected
and had to be removed.
TheY exercise,
they're all up to 35 minutes.
One of the radIo operators had become
incapable of using his set and the
efficiency of the rocket launcher team
was that impact.
They have rocket launches
attacking section had lost all sense of
urgency,
noticed,
bunching,
and indecision is they enter the would
occupied by the enemy almost
immediately.
The section commander,
I tried to use a map to find the
location of our headquarters and the
prisoners escalade had to have the way
pointed out to him.
Although he was in plain sight,
700 yards away over open country,
50 minutes off to taking the drug.
Radio communication had become
difficult,
if not impossible,
but the men are still capable and that's
the stain,
the physical effort.
However constructive action was till
attempted by those retaining a sense of
responsibility in spite of physical
symptoms,
but one hour and 10 minutes after taking
the drug was one man climbing a tree to
feed the birds.
The troop commander I gave up admitting
that he could no longer control himself
or his men
and they're all laughing and shit.
Self then relapsed into laughter.
Wow.
They're all his weapons.
Weapons on acid.
They didn't know about asset back then.
Full charge.
They know they didn't know.
They didn't know about the full charge,
that's for sure.
You could follow the full charge on
twitter and you should and you will.
It is the full charge.
It's that simple.
And if you want to fucking get crazy and
spell his name,
it's f u l c h irin iron like the metal
I r o n matt.
Full tron.
Thank you for having me man.
It's great brother.
Thanks for being on.
Good to see you again.
As always.
Um,
that's it.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Ladies and james will be back next week.
Next monday.
In fact to day the sponsor was ting.
Go to [inaudible] dot ting.com
and save 25 bucks off of any ting device
and you can also go to onnit.
Go to all.
And,
and that's.
and it used the codeword rogan and save
10 percent off any and all supplements.
All right,
we'll be back next week.
Enjoy your weekend.
Uh,
if I see you fuckers in vegas for the
ufc,
say hi.
And a much loved big kiss.
Oh my god.